[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes sir
yes sir
behold
spartacus
[Laughter]
talk to me y'all know what time it is
what's going on david james oroz what's
going on
how am i level sounding
asa already in the building what's going
on
salute ksit what's going on brother we
need therapy lord metroid i see you
adams
sans hope i got that right
black card salute mr glass salute what's
going on
okay play tell v-ho
[Music]
let's talk about it hey plato what's up
awful grim bulls what's up razor sharp i
like that razor rhythm razor sharp i
like that a pong saw what's going on i
gotta get punk solo wrench
paul gonna be putting it down i gotta
talk about that it's gonna rdx son of
fat with the 279 i believe canadian sony
vp court and he was wearing ps5 ta we
know we heard about that very
unfortunate sick slayer what's going on
kojim what's going on thomas what's up
big show today big show obviously we got
the legendary acer
game on daily you know what i'm saying
very intelligent brother i love talking
to him we're gonna pick his brain and of
course we got them topics
um might not be no addict today actually
definitely not gonna be no added to the
attic is really going through it and
you've got a couple of our personal
meanings so send some love to the young
wolf
definitely going through a lot of pain
right now a lot of pain i have my own
wisdom too about to be taken out and i
know that feeling so he's getting close
he's gonna have to get that done
but um yeah lisa drummond what's up
black conflict x my babes
yes there is
good to see you thomas what's up so yeah
it's gonna be a good show let me just
show you the king gonna pull up
he's gonna have a lot to say you already
know that's gonna be something and uh
saul is gonna be it's gonna be spicy
yeah
it's gonna be good it's gonna be good
but we're gonna definitely get into it
little metro attic got sick by playing
shinobi
yo y'all stupid he gotta run that back
you gotta run that back [ __ ] so bad i
gotta change my um
his payment info and get mommy oh yeah
you gotta do today that's true you ain't
you ain't give your tribute punk soul
that's what happened
where's your where's your little logo to
show that you're in the room
i am spontaneous
the bringer of rain
it's about to be on in the realm you
already know shout out rockstar steve so
look let me get up out of here let me
get uh my man asap in here we're gonna
have some fun today
gaming fun times get tops good to see
y'all
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until the time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when
um
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
messaging people don't aim
check
[Music]
be your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boy you
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i always been a nerd never been
a loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to starter regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
all on twitter but i'm anti-social love
my city but i'm still by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and want to compare me to freddie
and jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
fire this is that yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until the time to get this
show started so um
and turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people on aim
check my
vocals but i'm anti-social love my city
but i'm still by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you ain't gotta say
it i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who
let's do it
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
and be like a young wolf but then they
would mistake me for addict if i can
imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a new
vendor i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny work to cognito who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swearing away something but really be
stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
mike already spicy already crazy
here
and we are live
welcome to the i love podcast llc and
also live on lordsagaming.net episode
number 236. it's another glorious sunday
we're back at the round table on the
lord's day i'm extremely excited about
our special guests and we've got
playstation spoticus
series s winning black friday and vince
impella heading battlefield to discuss
so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose quiet
demeanor and insightful perspective
regarding the games industry has
uplifted his peers within the realm of
game journalism and content aggregation
introducing the host of the asa game on
daily twitch and youtube channels plus
co-founder of the game on daily.com
aggregate platform
the lord of objectivity and technology
who always finds a way to bring proper
balance to the source
live from the uk and finally making his
debut into the realm of the lords
my man lord asa from game on daily how
we doing sir
oh i love that i'm i'm just a humble
nerd and i'm thrilled to be here i've
been watching iop from the sidelines as
uh i love what you've built i love what
you do every week with the lords of
gaming.net and with this podcast and
with the community that you've got that
i count myself part of so
to be here with the front row seat for
spartacus and what's going to go down
cannot wait
i appreciate you something i don't know
how spartacus ended up
yo
[Laughter]
thank you for the car words so much
respect for what you guys do as well in
the game on daily platform but first how
are you doing first what games are you
playing man what's going on with you man
oh games well i've got well deep into
demon souls this week i've never really
played many of the souls games um
and i figured eldon ring's coming out
fairly soon and i should get into this
so i can probably like have opinions on
what's going on with it and demon souls
is the oldest and the newest of them at
the same time so i figured that's a good
starting point i've been
deep in there i'm doing it properly and
doing it without any youtube or any
guidance or any of this cheating stuff
that the kids do
it's deep and it's hard and it's fun but
i play loads of stuff i'm all over every
platform
vr and all the rest of it yeah i just
had to jump in there a little bit yeah
he called the paws on you
listen asa is well versed into king
paul's yeah
yeah souls is cool man i mean especially
with elder green coming out that's
probably a good thing to try to get
yourself i mean they don't have any new
games to play so you might as well go
back and play some old stuff
i'm just saying you already owe it all
right christmas it is a dry christmas
you are out of control anyway so
normally we'd have the four horsepower
we are down a horseman please send some
love to our brother lord attic he's
going through it man he's got that that
wisdom tooth surgery coming up man he's
just trying to make it he's just trying
to make it so send some love to attic
he's been hurting this whole week and uh
she tried to he tried to give it a go
but he won't be there this week but send
some love um i'm actually before we i'm
gonna get your intro sorry then because
super chats are flying in already but uh
we still got the uh three horsemen of
gaming
and of course we have our most technical
gaming laws the solo gamer who lives
with a single player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
camera clarity and lord patriarch of the
iron bank
my man lord sovereign with that new fit
how we doing sir i'm officially in the
bushes what i look nice
i look crispier
while i dig out my camera going probably
gotta got that sure sure
crispy sound crispy picture so finally
finally i got it rocking so i'm glad to
do that um yeah i'm good otherwise uh
it's gonna be a hectic month a lot of
running around
i'll be traveling at the end of the
month for the holidays and just it feels
like everything sort of piles up at the
same time so mm-hmm
it's crazy
you want to get a few super chats
because they will come some flew in
already yeah i'll get those yeah
real quick i haven't played much of
anything but i did finally okay so
gangnam rapper trigger happy happy the
original danganronpa oh you doing oh yo
maddie oh my baddie from definitely dude
loves that he be going hard in the paint
for that game no but yeah and the thing
is colin's been going hard for that game
forever yeah i actually downloaded it on
the vita way back when i just never
never played it um
but yeah it showed javita some love
yeah it did back in the day but you know
i mean just recently i just showed my
video some love oh you did that's a
beautiful thing i i i'm an idiot and got
rid of mine so i have to go no no i got
three of them
i have to go get it back for triple the
price oh yeah yeah
yeah
especially if you're gonna get the 5g i
mean the the two what is it two g one or
three g whatever i don't want to have
like an lte kind of event yeah yeah yeah
that's when it was only available that's
yeah
yeah yeah you was like lay down to stay
down you got yeah
all right let me read these super tests
quickly oh also real quick so uh i'm
gonna
waste your guys time a little bit a
little bit later on
you know you know how we get you know
everybody gets spam right everybody gets
so
lognet spam is a special kind of spam
yeah it comes into my my mailbox
and a lot of times it's just stupid like
bot stuff right right every now and
again it seems like the you get an email
that wasn't written by a bot per se but
a very stupid human
so
i i'm gonna i'm gonna read this one oh
this is special let's get this oh
yeah this could be a segment moving
forward oh all right let's get it let's
get it let me do it i'll do it later
okay let me read the super chats we got
rdx son of a fat with the 2.79 super
chat sony vp got cut
yeah yeah okay i wanna let me just
address it now real quick let's get it
out
rules of engagement today guys um
we will not like if you if you're gonna
super chat uh please don't be explicit
about what's going on of the allegations
that are uh that are uh happening at the
moment it's not that we won't uh
approach such things but we will
approach such things in this finality we
will not approach anything in its uh
assumptions or or whatever i don't care
what you saw i don't care anything about
that stuff but again right now it's
accusation so uh please be respectful
with the super chats uh when it's going
into that area yeah you can have
innuendos right but what i would say is
please be respectful because you're
sharing your money
and we want to read your super chats
absolutely for sure and
and
we're not
we're going to handle it respectfully as
well not because it's a very very
serious topic so
the less jokes around it the better yeah
please please all right absolutely so
and we got david hot right five dollar
super chat
let's get it lord's day we outside yes
then we have the dutch rudder with the
five dollar super chat when molly knew
said you can plant a seed and watch it
grow he didn't think about king planting
his seeds everywhere wow
yes he did the fable reference
if there's something that molly knew
knew was that that was gonna happen yeah
somebody's gonna do that
then we got heart geek chinese five
dollar super chat xbox proclaims i'm
spartacus iop game fast salute to the
lords on this fine lords day welcome to
the realm asa thank you sir yes sir
hello
then let's put the crest in the chat for
angel the newest member of the aisle
absolutely blesses thank you put the
crush in the chat no doubt all right
then we got a couple more that just came
in and then we will move on
gamer live studio 5
jamaican jim ryan got some explaining to
do about that playstation plus game pass
sony fanboys are getting played yet
again but i love to say it wow
wow kind of crazy yeah and we got black
conflict
[Applause]
fight the power brother
if you haven't played chorus you need to
yes yes
actually where did it drop on the drop
on pc i saw both consoles actually if
you uh go to lords of gaming.net we have
a fantastic review by lord flame of
course because it's up it's been up for
a few days so go check that out lord's
game but i don't see it in game pass
stop it
it exists just because it's not a game
fast oh
you know what and this is the part where
king says nice to see you
you know what i'm happy about yeah it
seems you know how excited we were when
we saw it yeah and a lot of times you
know that excitement doesn't pan out
with this game like probably check out
michael it might be crazy when it gets a
game time
check out my boyfriend
that it is fire check it out word flame
god bless all right last one before we
move on we have uh
lord meyerhoof remember for four months
thank you sir good day lords on a fine
lord's day thanks for the great content
also can't underestimate the little man
never underestimate the little man get
you a little man emoji right now i feel
yeah i think it'll be a nice day for a
little bit just a guess just again so we
all good for now we're all good yeah all
right and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the excess
gamer oh
the prophet of xbox mommy
king of the state u.s catches me king of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement oh be
loving lord king how we doing sir
i'm doing as good as devin haney devin
haney uh had a stern test yesterday with
um
devin haney is the wbc
uh
135 or 40 pound
uh champion
he had a stern test with uh jojo diaz
last night and it was fantastic all
those people that are watching fights or
following fights today we have uh tank
versus cruz that's going to be a great
fight that's going to be at 5 p.m today
so as soon as i get out of here i'm
going straight over there um but it was
he he finally walked through the fire he
got caught with some really good shots
and he he manned up and he showed
exactly what he was made of and i truly
appreciate a young boy uh turning into a
man right in front of our eyes he
actually went through that fire um and
it was a good test he did a lot of
masterful things so fantastic stuff
right now
i'm in game pass so if a game doesn't uh
actually hit game pass guess what it
don't hit king
you can throw it but i ain't gonna catch
it
yo it's a game called anvil right and
it's in the preview program
this game all right so at first it's a
roguelike right and
at first i had dismissed it right
because i tried it a little bit and i
was like oh looks like a pc type of game
and then
i went back in something
like dug at me yeah went back into it
and they have uh these breakers they're
called breakers okay right and the
breakers are
uh the the avatars that you use inside
the game each breaker has different uh
move sets that they are they start off
with right but you have to gain money to
unlock certain breakers uh
preview program acid beta
yes sir yes sir i told you i'm a beta
boy i'm playing halo so you can't get me
i'm right there
if it matters to me i'm back bee
[Laughter]
so these breakers are incredible right
um
and they're
when you start to play the game you
really get entrenched with how the
breakers move control is key to the game
so it's a stick shooter uh and each
weapon
has a different
feel to it the game
literally each breaker can have at least
10 different fills to it while you start
to max them out the game is extremely
hard but what is different about this
row light you can have your friends join
in and play
in the game with you pause uh and help
you beat some of these harder bosses i
got to a level five boss and it was
incredibly hard ace is shaking his head
like he's he's played this game
but uh
i'm i'm telling you this game is one
game for you to watch i downloaded a
couple of other games that hit game pass
i've been playing uh halo
uh had a up and down week this week so
if you're looking at my oh yeah boy
these dude the sweaty's getting there
they're starting to get rough they rank
that rank
[ __ ] yeah so
i'm loving what i'm saying i i like the
fact that they fixed a couple of things
when it comes to the progression of the
characters and stuff that you can't
unlock i love the fact that i have the
ninja core out oh you got it down nice
nice nice right and it's gone
so you can't get it if you didn't play
last week so i love the exclusive part
here we go oh you like the fomo you're
like
so so the dudes be like oh yo is that in
the store i could buy that right now nah
dawg
you had to participate for this
i had my participation trophy i'm
running around wearing it with the with
the nasty colors but i do love it um
no destiny
and i downloaded fortnite to play with
my son
again there goes my embroidery uh when
it matters to me then it's going to be
yeah but uh that's that's about it
that's the only thing
no doubt and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself that should not be
no incognito spreading that romance in
the realm of iop not telling what you
want here but what you need to hear
shout out to defining duke the latest
episode myself mr maddie plays have some
good discussion talk about that star
feel talk about what's going on with the
game awards having that fun talk also if
you want that exclusive lsm dd ultimate
check that out we talk about the movie
industry really good discussion about
how games and film are kind of like
gotta marry getting all paired up let me
check that out also um the last word
return ivantes by homie the cheetah of
course todd got travis great show we
again we have our boy ill physics on
talking about the bungie's 30th
anniversary everything that's going on
with that and uh yeah getting ready the
campfire's starting to heat up next week
in destiny so check that out and uh for
as far as me as far as gaming again like
king halo infinite been rocking you know
what i'm saying still around what i can
a multiplayer still trying on guards of
the galaxy it's been so busy for me i
was like every time i try to play the
game i got to do something i'm like i'm
loving this game but i keep getting
interrupted and that's a game i like the
focus that is very story and you got to
listen because the banter is so good so
um yeah other than that just getting
ready for a new dungeon and campaign
next week but um yeah other than that we
got to do that time of the month
right quick you know what i'm saying
because you know what it is um so shout
out to lawyergaming.net man shout out to
everybody the team everybody's been
doing anything um tremendous tremendous
competition for this award every month
um
crazy writing talent it's been it's been
really cool to see everyone kind of come
together but um
this month we got to celebrate a
specific lord man specific lord has kind
of gone above and beyond he's been
really killing it in the month of
november had nostalgic pieces about the
halo anniversary kind of kind of getting
everybody in their fields just old
school pieces 360 og stuff and then um
he's been doing a lot of multi-platform
stuff whether it be reviews
um editorial pieces all that stuff man
so hopefully he could get in here
if he can't accept this award but if not
we will still announce it but um yeah we
got to celebrate for the month of
november the lord dizzy scribe of the
month the og connecticut's own gene
schatzmeyer put your hands together man
holding it down once again
gene if you can get it here get your
wall get your little speech
yeah jim been doing it man big fan of
gene he's been holding it man again the
editorials also uh please uh square
circle square cross it's like a
playstation editorial that he does every
month state of place today he's been
killed with it man so we had to give him
his roses hopefully he could get in
solve maybe read the super chats one
more time give him a few minutes he did
say he was going to try to make it i
just want to make sure he can get his uh
roses right quick
we have uh cedric h ten dollars for chat
jamaican jim is trying to get that 75
foot yacht but phil already bought a
cruise ship
let's see
then we got the man who got them horns
member for 18 months thank you so much
sir much love to the lords and asa
hashtag sauce
crystal d hashtag jamaican jim ryan
hashtag spartacus
then we got mo b
five dollar super chat it's the lord's
day and i'm representing the lords from
down south salute everybody hit that
like button beautiful thank you sir no
doubt no doubt then we got wandering
dutch remember for nine months shout out
to the dutch salute lords need a beard
in the realm today king holding it down
yes he is yes he is i got i got rid of
mine this morning and of course we don't
have the i was watching you play the
other day uh wandering it was incredible
mm-hmm
then we have demonomics oh gene is here
gamernomics member for two months shout
out to you sir played the artful escape
after listening to king talk about it on
the last episode nice one of the best
experiences i had playing a game in a
long time yeah it's salute salute yeah
thank you then we have raiden blade two
pound super chat hello lords and we're
at work listening wish i was home no
doubt but i'm glad we can keep you
company exactly then we have elemental
peel haven't seen that
five dollar super chat someone got to
tell somebody to stop eating the sesame
cake of game pass congo references
and let's see what else we got
uh we got a little no we have we got
jake
you're done you're done
enough respect iron laws can't wait for
halo seen the destiny dlc i'm not
falling for it i'm done with destiny
i can't wait let's go chief i don't know
why you can't deal with it because it
ain't a gay pastor
but look back to business man like i
said earlier it's that time of the month
the scribe of the month the person who's
been putting in the most work the month
of november like i said brother you've
been killing it lord gene i want to
shout you out the halo anniversary stuff
the great ideas i love i've always
butchered circle cross square one of
those i think i got it right but um you
know the playstation editorial and then
just the reviews and a lot of good
introspective pieces internationally and
what's going on in the industry so again
the scribe of the month the oh gee the
goddess you're kind of the front runner
let's keep it a party you got it that
guy you know what i said
put your hands together speak speech
well thanks guys i'm i'm glad to be the
guy i love hanging out with you guys
love having fun salute it's great to
catch up with you guys once a month
every so often you know see what's going
on mm-hmm no doubt man now we gotta get
together pretty soon yeah we got we got
plans
yeah it's all this way something that
was returning you know saying that we
actually met in person and i'm we we're
looking forward to it the lord's off
magical powers yes
yes yes and i like when we talk of the
devs he got the suit jacket does he give
me the regular it's awesome it gives me
the reggie phil's of mayfield
[Laughter]
don't let uh gene fool you he's a
speedster yes he's a beast he's your
base we need we need that gene juju we
need that yes yes yes finding out those
games but brother thank you make sure
you hit solve up so that you get
rewarded you know there's a lot of new
stuff on the store man gotta get some
get yourself hooked up man
no doubt all right guys you're all natty
i don't know if he's getting that i
don't know if he's kidding
i don't know gene looks like he walks on
the wild side
i'm done idiots
walking around you don't know
i think you know i'll get you into
something yeah yeah you definitely
yo gee appreciate you brother have a
good sunday and always keep up the good
work thank you brother thank you
no doubt no yeah
one more before we move on real quick we
got gerald mack remember for 15 months
oh hell the iop salute please keep that
same energy spartacus ruins gaming it
hurts developers no rental services
hashtags same energy we will get one to
be true we will get to the topic when we
get to the topic
[Music]
we're supposed to be such a quiet week
yeah remember we ain't talking about
keep up the good work hey king did you
get pumped faked with the tank fight i
thought it was saturday night not sunday
oh no no no i knew it was sunday uh
floyd is a wonderful promoter he let
devin have his day
you know and a lot of times we have
fights on top of fights and you're
fighting for viewership uh no let devin
have his day and then you do the next
day tank is a big enough drawer he can
actually draw on a sunday
no doubt no doubt football that's crazy
all right so we all good yeah we're
caught up all right so look now we got
all the business out the way we got this
amazing guest that's been patient
we gotta focus with lol asa man his
video game system history his journey
into content creation and tech analysis
and of course what led him to
co-founding the amazing game on daily
aggregate platform so lower acer let's
start from the very beginning what was
some of the first video game systems you
had and what got you into gaming
oh i'm i'm not a young pup that might
take a little while been playing games
for a long long time oh we like that we
like that let's go love it the all right
the very first one that i had this one
like you can discount this but i had an
atari st and that was my parents and it
was in their bedroom so i got very
little hands-on with that but the first
game that i fell in love with so was
this um let's go like adventure
playground like swings and slides and
things there's a little heart with a
tuckshop and a couple of pool tables and
at the back
they had a nes and a mega drive a sega
genesis
so the first two games that i saw that
were there
yes that's going to be my life now
sonic
yes sonic 2. that's why that's why
that's there
and they had on the nerves they had
mario and uh some wrestling game and
this wrestling game um
whenever i hear you guys talk about your
history playing games you've got this
this arcade where you're all putting
these quarters down and challenging each
other right quarters like 25 cents right
yeah yes yes yeah so so in the uk it's
like they were a pound so that's
basically 1.50 yes oh no wow
[Laughter]
that's where you sit and take on all
challenges i played that a bunch um
but it was sonic that had my heart so i
went with sega systems from then on and
this is
and this is where i'm different to
everyone else though because you hear a
lot of people from that generation they
look at the the console wars now people
arguing like xbox and playstation and
they say ah i'm not above that but in my
day it was nintendo against sega
it never was for me never was for me
really that's why that's why i'm
different to everyone else now for me i
prefer to take i didn't have enough
money for everything so i had to say
good consoles
i didn't really have like
many friends at school or anything like
that that were that into gaming so the
arguments never happened what i had was
i had a cousin that had a super nintendo
and a neighbor that had a super nintendo
and i would spend as much time as i
could playing that with them if i could
and they come back and play on the sega
and there were no arguments there was no
conflict everyone loved playing games
correct it's a connection
yeah
okay so
the kids weren't the only ones that
participated in this fanboy war console
war actually the companies did and they
had commercials
being that we're in the states and we
saw these commercials uh you can't do
this on the tandos genesis does you know
we had those type of commercials
did you have those type of commercials
that promoted uh you know console wars
over there that's a good question
nowhere near to the extent that you had
it no some of them would have come over
and i would have missed them a bunch but
we didn't have the whole there was very
little talk of blast processing and
nintendo and all that kind of thing like
it wasn't non-existent you did catch
wind a bit but
no different scene gotcha yeah enough
fair enough continue continue start you
about to get into as far as uh just
going over friends houses and you know
each one have not really there wasn't
really family everybody would if you
didn't have it you know you went over
your friend's house and vice versa to go
go see it like that was that right
continue you was about to talk about
that
yeah so i went from from the sega mega
drive i had saved up all of my money for
the for the mega cd that was a terrible
add-on to the console
it was it was terrible
oh i had there was an airplane game like
tomcat something or other yeah and i
don't think i had sherlock holmes no um
no i didn't play much of that but i was
saving up for that because i'm an idiot
and i'm not saving up for the mushroom
shape 32x as well but beforehand i
didn't get it before i got it suddenly
there was the sega saturn so i jumped
onto that and it was on
the sega saturn i discovered um jrpgs
like i love the jrpgs i hadn't played
storied games particularly i know they
existed on the generations before but i
was more pick up and play like here's my
friends we're going to do some smash tv
or whatever and then sega saturn i was
like oh these games these can tell
stories
can i have some titles please some names
stunning force three panzer green saga
those are the standards oh you would
solve about to be best this is have you
played shining the holy ark
i actually missed it that's one that's
on my backlog oh my god my backlog is
long but i've got i've got this beauty
beautiful
if anyone has an opportunity to ever
touch that it's still it's an amazing
game
that's one of my top ones
but then you hear people talking final
fantasy vii let's go and that's when
yeah he's back home let's go bring it in
bring it in leave some little come on oh
brother fraud
that was his
that was his pregame to the main event
[Laughter]
since that point i've had every
playstation
every sega
the dreamcast introduced online gaming
to me i hadn't really done much pc
gaming up to that point to the dreamcast
fantasy star online quake three yes blew
my mind expanded my horizons yes and i
went to the only place you can go from
there from playing quake three in four
player team death match on on the
dreamcast oh yeah the only place you can
go is the quake three on the pc
first started my pc game in nice and i
played a bunch there the
original xbox came out loved that
don't have many memories of it to be
honest i had it it had quite a short
life i played fusion frenzy and all the
rest of it i had some games on it but i
don't have strong memories
it's funny because guys i'll let you go
we missed out on that like we were so
caught up in halo and all these other
stuff that i hated
it i hated it did you play it with other
people
that's what it is you got to play that
i'm not i'm basically the only child my
sister was seven years old
it's a party game so yeah playing it by
yourself i can see how you hate
[Music]
yeah obviously the game that i actually
got the xbox four was halo and i played
a hell of a lot of payload and
absolutely adore halo as i'm sure
everybody does all right so played a
hell of a um
the i mentioned fusion friendly i went
through a phase with the it was at the
playstation in the saturn where i was
still doing this thing where i have a
console my friends have a console and
we'd like get together and i take my
saturn with seven controllers and
have a bit of drink and we play some
games and we'll get the playstation out
with that as well um fusion frenzy just
kind of carried that on a little bit
that's why i mentioned that one nice
when the 360 came out and the 360 the
first two or three years of the 360 were
banging oh fantastic times massive
gears of war
yes yes we just rushed past the
playstation glory days yeah
and i wanted to ask about some niche
systems too because playstation
obviously playstation number one is not
that niche but a big dignity
graphics and stuff like that wasn't
there that's how i was gonna ask him
like in because i'm assuming all of this
asa is is uk i'm assuming am i correct
okay
okay so my question to you is
for us you know again thanks to king the
import scene in new york city a lot of
times we take this for granted but i
wanted to know
like was the turbo graphics was the 3do
was you know that stuff readily
available
you know around at that time or was it
something that you knew about it was
just like hey i'm not really into that
i'm gonna stay away from it it was just
way too much
the so the 3do and the atari jaguar
were
available and i didn't have them and
they just they got no traction didn't do
anything over here but you could find
them again i went to um egx a few weeks
ago a month ago uh it was a bit of a
dead show but they have their retro
section and there were a whole load of
systems there that i've never seen in my
life
wow um
playstation 2 those glory days that
you're talking about yes i largely did
gloss over the playstation 2 i don't
know
interesting how that happens
i don't know but it did um i might still
own it it's probably kicking around
somewhere it's kicking around
oh yeah
see the thing is
you know for for us i think obviously
the the oh there you go
exclusively oh
i'll forgive the final fantasy talk
wait a second
don't tell me you still have a crt you
still have a crt
okay oh so you you're going to tune it
up in the back so it can play uh through
hdmi right yeah yeah through a scott
adapter here gotcha oh yeah you have you
have s card you have a bunch of ways you
can play it now um
but
i think what for me and i don't know if
you guys felt the same way when when the
xbox came out right it became
it became my de facto third-party
console so i was playing on that most of
the time i was playing the xbox first
party stuff third-party stuff that
finally started coming to xbox i was
playing there because it was the best
version of it and like if it wasn't at
that moment that's when my playstation
became the exclusive box
it was that ps2 generation so
i would say from the from the moment
xbox started getting those like when
they got gta and stuff like that that's
when the transition happened and i don't
have a lot of those memories of being on
playstation apart from those exclusives
like mgs2 and live too that will make
them devil may cry initially like stuff
like that like beyond that
i didn't stay on that console like that
i rocked the hell out of my place nature
i want it i want to hit ace's thought
process on that playstation generation
and again and also don't forget i i
didn't get your turbo graphics and so i
need that too as well continue
my turbo graphics never never heard of
it never saw one yeah okay so where he's
at they would have a pc engine right it
would not have a turbo graphics and
if if he's not in that region where they
targeted them
uh a pc engine would have never hit the
they wasn't even advertising you know
what it is it's just because again for
us for the states and
the the marketing right and i remember
you know the loud aggressive marketing
the keith courage debunk so it's just
interesting to see how a console in
another region sometimes just won't make
traction where it's not you know you
know ace is like oh no that wasn't even
nobody
yeah never got a foothold there and that
was its biggest uh fatal flaw that's
interesting yeah continuously this is
this is very interesting because i
always like to hear
internationally how things because in
our mind from the states we think it's
everybody's experience at the same thing
we are and just you know it's different
but continue this is great it's good
stuff it is so i do have to say i'm not
in london so london might be different
you might get different
wasn't in london then either but like
in the city maybe maybe things were
targeted differently but i am no not so
much
um
yeah so did the xbox the xbox 360 had
those first two three years they were
absolutely banging every game that was
coming out was just like wow gotta play
that bioshock best demo that any game
has ever had best demo yes um
and then and then two human happened and
it kind of
and then microsoft seems to just like
give up really for a while the 360
there was way less after the after the
third year way less going on and they
started focusing on connect and
following that we mark yeah
[Music]
speaking of i've not mentioned nintendo
at all
at all that is true
um
i'll upset some people when they do oh
oh oh
spicy let's get it
so
we'll go through the rest of the journey
first and then we'll double back and no
doubt explain the lack of nintendo
um
so yeah i moved into pc at that point i
played a lot of pc games for the latter
half of that generation um playstation 3
and xbox 360. i had the consoles i
didn't even touch the exclusives for
about four years oh wow and then
on the cusp of the xbox one and the
playstation 4 coming out then i decided
to double back and check what i've
missed and catch up with like the last
of us and things like that
gone by
um
and the xbox one and playstation 4
this is a weird time in my life where
i've gone into pc gaming and i got right
deep into like properly nerd stuff on pc
gaming and i had a pc at that point that
had four graphics cards in it oh well
he's out here
it was it was ridiculous but my pc was
like it was like 18 teraflops or
something like that um
like he was flexing it was
it was nuts right it didn't necessarily
work did you have dual sli going like
how did that work crossfire yeah it was
um so the
290x i had um two 290x's and one of
their 295x which was a double graphics
card it was already crossfired right so
back in those days crossfire wasn't
terrible because amd had a specifically
crossfired card at their highest end
so it was reasonably well supported
sometimes
it was a mess and that pc ran higher
than anything you've ever touched
so
yeah it had two separate rewards calling
loose it's probably nerdy though so i've
got this 18 teraflop machine here and
then the xbox one and the playstation 4
come out
but they're 30 frames per second he said
with their with their 30s
i respect it i respect it i respect it
because at the end of the day even the
realm got mad at me because i did leave
for pc during the xbox live
i did it was a bit because the phrase
once i started experiencing the 60 it
was hard to go back like unless it was
exclusive so i understood that but i
want to back up just one quick thing on
pc because you said towards the end of
the 360. jen you know obviously connect
gets introduced you know they start to
do some things that you're not really
keen with right and i needed to know
like what
were the games on pc
that was like yo i am here i am loving
this like give me that
so i i went through a shameful mmorpg
phase i played a lot of warcraft
is really you know part of the 96 97
club because you know us brainiacs link
up this way
what what was your uh your class uh in
world of warcraft or world of warcraft
oh that's a that's a complicated
question i had i had all of them um
right but my first one that i actually
stuck with for a while was a shaman
gentleman okay
listen
did you okay
two questions and i know this can go
extra long so i'm not gonna go you know
extra long on this uh topic but two
questions uh did you sell gold and did
you buy gold
i'm not the entrepreneur that you are
okay
i i would make i would okay i had a
in-game wife
um
and she would make uh
you know items for me that i can in turn
sell
at the marketplace
and then get money and then we split it
so it was it was kind of crazy but
yeah after i spent real money on it i
was like i got to get out of it
i'm glad you got your budget so
you doing the pc stuff then i want to
say you saw the xbox one the ps4
those 30 frame systems for the most part
i mean there was some 16.
it was um there were some it's funny
that because now like a year into this
generation if anybody goes back to play
those old consoles and they're where i
was in 2013 they're like
this doesn't feel nice right it's not
unpleasant the load times the frame rate
[Music]
and everybody else is there now with
these wonderful new consoles but um
but i did have them and funnily enough
between the two
because i already had power in the back
with the pc the one that was more
interesting to me was actually the xbox
really one
the original vision for it was connect
right it was like well now you've got
something that does what my pc doesn't
okay right
so i'm not impressed by the hardware but
i might do something new like i'll give
that one a go so i got that before the
playstation 4. okay um
and then and then they dropped all of
that and made the xbox one a week of
playstation 4 for a while
so
the wrong person was in charge right um
okay so speaking to to your love of uh
microsoft and the death of sega because
you actually had a chance to watch the
death of sega
and
overseas
sega thrived a little bit longer
right because
correct me if i'm wrong the mega drive
was still profitable
in um overseas in europe uh not like in
america in america it had got defunct
the last uh shipments uh sega usa they
stopped putting them out and they
stopped producing consoles
but over in europe they were still
making consoles and stuff like that and
then it finally died out
you got a chance to watch the
playstation actually put the lay down
stay down on them
and you went into the microsoft world
and you said they were hitting in the
beginning they were hitting and then
along came donny and and messenger yo yo
train up all right
can we get to the field era because we
let's let's just let's
he just said that to connect the
uniqueness of the dodd's error i want
you to drag this out with the connection
all right so let's see let's get to the
let's get to the connections
he had a very weird mandate from above
his head yeah right he he was tasked
with
taking xbox to a service based thing
that people weren't ready for yes and
phil's managed it don didn't but
most executives would have tripped over
that as well it was a very difficult ass
to get gamers to accept subscriptions
and services
yeah i think any executive that doesn't
have a base in gaming already is gonna
have i mean matric did have that but
he's not a gamer in the sense he doesn't
understand gaming oh no
no no no no we will not do that we will
not make excuses for this man actually
putting my xbox on life support but it
is true
tragic is not fail in any way shape or
form yeah he acknowledged that right he
tried to abort the baby and right he
can't do this we are not going to act
like this man and he's he's done it
again so
okay so once is the mistake two is on
purpose
that's fine but i'm just con like asa
i'm contextualizing it
the end result is still the same i'm
just content you just want a white wasp
like like he was satan
that you know what king [ __ ] is just
silly civilization he would have burned
the books
so what you do is actually you will
pillage the village and you burn down
all knowledge all the traces have
and i like when he said
a lot of other uh you know executives
would have tripped over that
right but feel dominance
it is
right so uh let's let's okay so now that
we're in the light let's look we haven't
finished did you know this you know this
look asa has a halo over his head now
that he's talking about this
i never would have dreamed that my
system history would get this messy
i love it it's classic
um i don't know that's today isn't it
that's pretty much brought us up to now
so i've got the the playstation 5. i've
got the series x i've got a pc that i
use a lot i've got i love my virtual
reality i know most people don't talk
about it
yeah
and
that's where i am into the future i'm
i'm not antagonistic with anyone i love
all of those platforms um and then
there's nintendo yes
yes let's go let's bring it back there
we go
so there's a couple of things the so the
other thing that was missing from my
entire history there was any portable
gaming right um anything on a phone
anything on a vita i know you love your
vitas and a switch
those don't work for me because the only
places that i would play them are like
on trends and things and i can't i'll
just be sick so i've got no no space in
my life for portable gaming so it's not
that i hate those systems but they just
don't work for me but nintendo in
general this is where it gets a little
bit more controversial my opinions on
them so i loved the nez and the super
nintendo and like i said the first
nintendo game that i saw was mario
brothers three and i had a great time
jumping across those platforms and doing
some mario stuff and then the n64 came
out
and mario 64 that everybody loves
everybody loves mario 64.
i picked up that controller and i saw a
brightly colored garish wasteland of
nothing
one enemy
and it was it was ugly to me and then i
picked up the controller and tried to
move around and it wasn't tight like the
2d marios and i went to jump on the
goomba thing and it was way harder to
judge than than mario was before i was
looking around like
i can see where this 3d gaming is going
but this is not it
this is sparse and boring
wow wow this is spicy i've never heard
this i've never heard a take like this
he's not telling a lie oh right it's
true
earlier stupid nintendo games i mean
that's super nintendo 64.
n64 games
they didn't have so many enemies on the
screen i would give them right so so
what the playstation was able to do like
with games like ape escape and stuff
like that they were able to
not have clean textures their textures
had a lot of tearing a lot of warping
and stuff like that the nintendo was
able to show clearer textures with less
enemies the playstation was able to move
more polygons and put more enemies on
the screen
so
asa is right he did see a colorful
wasteland of nobody
i just got to jump in real quick i got
you sorry i gotta ask him this because
i i'm trying to be respectful understand
your perspective even though we disagree
right but
i do
under i do i have to ask this part
because a lot of people
that love that error and love that feel
that's a touch point right clearly you
don't
but the thing is
the 64 and the adoption of the analog so
for you the movement still wasn't
precise like that didn't connect with
you was it coming so let's not
let's not pretend that n64 invented the
analog stuff oh that's what this is
you know i was i was a sega boy and i
had to three days okay
[Laughter]
yeah um
no i didn't i didn't struggle with that
so much and i did have an n64 i had two
games on the n64 and you can probably
guess what they are so i'm going to let
you know my two games in the n64
obviously as mario and then um
not mario i didn't know mario oh you
didn't own it playing america played
mario
golden knight golden eye
[Music]
all right so i had those two on the n64
and that's literally that was my entire
n64 catalogue
this is the most 64 slander it's great i
mean this is fun this is great unique
perspective he's like yo
he did not feel it you got to respect it
you got to respect it
real question quick question where the
wrestling game we always talk about were
they prominent over there at all wasn't
not nearly as big
not for me because um wrestling was on
sky and i didn't have it so i don't
think wrestling games were massive i
wasn't particularly into the characters
i don't even know who i was playing as
but it was a fighting game and it was
fun
i knew this was gonna
happen when he walked in the room
and he saw the sega mega drive
and he saw the the nes and he said
me
[Laughter]
i know i went yeah
it was never gonna hit no matter what
they came with it was never gonna hit
obviously that's so beautiful i respect
you
people's favorite game your favorite
yeah he was very disgusting it's just
funny because where i'm similar to asa
is you know obviously i kind of fell out
of love with nintendo during a certain
part but he fell out of love earlier
than me like he fell out of love with
people who were considering that still
the heyday and he's like nah that's not
it that's not it right
he fell out of love the moment he looked
at it he was like oh no
they'll die
until that point i was all over there i
didn't own the nintendo consoles but i
got access to them whenever i could i
played it whenever i could and i loved
them and the n64
yeah my one guilty of mission is zelda
ocarina of time i looked at that and i
saw mario and i didn't play it um
i i reckon i'd probably enjoy that but
you know as i was able to run in around
the field and it's just right now crazy
right now
this did not transition you to the
gamecube this did not transition you to
the wii
none of things inspired you to continue
ocarina of time was a mistake like i
reckon if i'd actually spent more than a
minute with it
that would have been a game for me so
that was a mistake um
hold my hands up on that one that's my
guilty admission but apart from that
nintendo very little for me i had a i
had a wii i had a wii u
very
little on them thing is nintendo also
you know how they price things like
their games are stupid price and they
don't go down and they were never
enticing enough to be worth full price
to me
yeah
[Laughter]
he said because y'all had no sale prices
on your games it was never enticing to
me
he said y'all want to charge full price
today the same price just started when
y'all launched it's a wrap oh i'm good
this is great i love unique perspective
man that ace is on his square when he's
like look they it just didn't appeal to
him
no it's not coming
but look this this is tremendous you
know and obviously it's it's interesting
hearing your journey and story you know
because you you pretty much the cool
thing i like though is that you've
experienced these things right because
one thing is a lot of people can have
very you know voiceless opinions but
they actually haven't tried it you know
i mean they just say hey they might not
think that's not for me but in your case
you're like no i tried it this was not
it you know and that's
but
but he actually was outside with it you
know yeah
acceptance is disgusting i love that i
love that that's it but yeah it did
obviously you come back the xbox right
there obviously that leads you to today
with the current generation and kind of
staying in with tech and everything like
that but um yeah it's got a let's cut
solve it and well king has a specific
question i did want to move on because i
got a ton of other questions for him but
um yeah man i wanted to get into
pre-game on daily talk and i wanted to
kind of get like the origin story as far
as like you know what inspires you into
just content creation and maybe the
interest into journalism
one secret came after game one daily for
me okay so in terms of like order of
events um game on the daily
um i did some writing for it so it used
to be uh a blog website essentially that
reviewed games and things like that and
gaz was writing it so most people
probably know the amazon daily already
um
he was running there and once upon a
time on a forum he decided i was fairly
eloquent with my opinions and asked me
to write a review for drive club
[Music]
club yeah
yeah so i did that i wrote a review as a
response rather than saying yes i was
like yeah it looked like this and i'm
writing a three-page review of it um
and carried on doing stuff for them for
a little while but then one one day he
messaged everyone that was involved with
it like he's thinking of doing a news
aggregation site do you want to be
involved with the news aggregation site
um he'd been using um n4d and things
like that
that were messy yeah
the messiness of it
you remember yeah well
i bit his hand off like yeah i do but
it's not going to be
it's not going to be an equivalent of
that it's going to be something way
bigger way more social way more driven
for community and things like that and
yeah i want to get involved with that
and put his hand off for it and we got
together and spent way too much money to
build this thing and we're still
building this thing um if you've never
been there game on daily is a content
aggregation platform it's a content
creation platform so you can go on there
and write we pull in
all sorts of news from all sorts of
people including loads of gaming.net on
all sorts of other platforms i know you
wear this shirt i respect that i respect
that see i'll see you right now yeah i
told you do you remember it came up on
the stream and it said anonymous and i
was like i asked oh that was you know
okay absolutely i appreciate the lord's
gaming
love and definitely love to use the
platform man we got we actually got to
use it more we'll talk afterwards
so yes
but it's built with all of these like
tools to support communities on it so
the way that it works at the moment if
you're using twitter at the moment and
you go inside using your twitter account
everybody that you follow on twitter if
they're already on game one day you'll
be following them and the news that you
see in your feed is all tailored around
what the people in your community are
talking about so at the moment not
enough people are using the site for all
these tools to work which means that me
and gaz have to like curate a lot of
stuff to keep it populated right not
supposed to work like that so when it
gets built up and when we've got more
people using it there's all kinds of
features to make sure the stuff that is
interesting to you is what floats to the
top of it
and that's what your feed is
and
it's just to start i start what we're
building there but um in terms of
content creation yeah so
gaza has always been very like on that
like he's said from the start we need to
have like a youtube presence we need to
be on social media people need to know
who we are yes and that's the opposite
i'm a massive introvert i was like no
yes we have one on this panel as well
we know that you and saab are very
similar
oh it's just like nope nobody needs to
know my name
oh my god this is solved yes you were
here
[Laughter]
30 years of my life like avoiding
cameras not letting people point them at
me i still do that outside of outside of
content creation if anyone's pointing
the camera and i'm like no i'm going to
leave the room
you do what you need to do um so how did
gas convert
i don't even know what's weird is it's
me that pushed for cameras on the go
live show on the saturday and then like
and that's because i watched
what's yours and i'm like this adds so
much to it to see people and we need to
do that so thank you for that yeah thank
you um
because i would watch people's podcasts
and i would see this little stupid
avatar bleep
and i said this is the most irritating
especially if you don't know who's
talking and then you got to follow the
bump and it just
it was just so irritating and
nonsensical and they will never retain
my viewership because i don't know if
the guy is angry i don't know if he
my thing is when a camera is on you you
have to present your best self right you
can't beat in a holy t-shirt you can't
be there with boogers in your nose you
can't be there what's not you know the
eyeballs you know coming out just not
coming out your ears you can't do these
things you have to present yourself in
the best light and then a lot of times
you have to clean up your background you
have to make yourself presentable right
so you want to respect the people's time
that's viewing you and you get so much
more do you know how animated uh gas is
yeah it's so much more from it oh yes
also when i'm with you
i can see your brain yeah yeah yeah when
i'm on the show and it's it gives so
much more so i do appreciate the fact
that you said you saw us do that and i
agree it's fantastic
yeah thank you for that um i said i
agree with you king you spot on because
it's again it was a struggle for us and
you know even though i'm teasing this
off i was the same too i was i was
resistant you know what i mean i didn't
want to do this we didn't want to do it
you know king is pushing king is pushing
now at the time i thought it was a
stupid promise i made to him well i'll
do it eventually when we get to x y and
z points
he's like yeah we're there we're there
so what's up where's your face where's
your face [ __ ] and i'm like all right
and then i did it and then once you got
over it it's fun but it it to king's
point and to as far as like him being on
game on daily i've been on game on daily
youtube channel you know you guys want a
great show and it's interesting because
you being the reserved one right i feel
you of gas is just like we don't get
like gas is the energy you go for the
sauce he's going to be spicy he's going
to mix it up and we love that but you
got you're like this perfect opposite
right this perfect ying to his yang and
the thing that i like about it is that
your personality shines through on
camera because you're sarcastic and
you're subtle and you're like i don't
know about that guys
and then you'll have your little i'm
like okay like i learned that you have
that side to you that you know you can
get in the trenches it's fun so i'm glad
you said that as far as you know guys
kind of helping you and then you guys
just said then you actually are the one
now pushing when the youtube channel hey
we need to be on camera as a result of
watching iop which thank you very humbly
to say that thank you
yeah no that's um that's it really what
goes on from there so content creation
actually i still struggle with constant
creation because uh gaza is a big
personality and big energy and it's hard
to stand up content alongside the source
and know what to do with it so that's an
ongoing thing for me but um you've seen
i do the technologies from time to time
and those those are hard work they take
a long time to put together and i don't
enjoy pixel counting and i don't enjoy
console wars
so
yeah but it's a passion for you but you
know it wait
yeah it gets off i gotta ask you guys
but it's content it's content i get it i
get it um because that the same for me
like
ever since i used to love
looking at that stuff thinking about it
kind of breaking it down
ever since and i love digital foundry
but ever since digital foundry has sort
of made that their hook
i don't care about it as much as ever
since
it just there's so much of it now that
it's it's a saturday like and again it's
kind of stopped now also whereas they
they come out with their comparisons but
you don't see the flame wars on twitter
over it anymore like you don't want to
see the
i guess you know
a certain machine edges out another one
right with a with a you know with a more
vocal fan base so i mean tell the truth
shane the devil phil dominus maximus
aurelia spencer said you will not have
power and he took it from you all right
so you said that you had speed and i
told you the day that one of your games
don't load up faster it's a wrap and
what happened your game stumbled out the
gate and my game got past your joy and i
was like yeah you didn't need the fake
ssd so okay so now that we got no power
no ssd and as big as hell
it's like okay
anytime anytime digital foundry does do
this because we all pixel counted
anybody that has a pc that was doing all
that uh um what was that we was doing 3d
effects what was that the the test uh
sovereign that we would do uh for the
game
yeah thank you sir
reading we know we did it at 3dmark
benchmarking yeah so we would do this
with each other what was your score what
was this called
and tell ourselves
did you practice this in the background
okay so we're not going to act like uh
sighs don't matter
pause and you know pixels don't matter
and these stuff do matter right now it
doesn't matter to the person when you
lost that battle i don't know how many
times i went to digital foundry and they
was like yeah the xbox is coming in at
900p i'm like come on man
why are you acting like it's a sports
team loss like it was like the knicks
lost it was it was
we took it for eight years we took it
that's why i try to wipe it away because
now we village in the village and we're
going to burn the books
it's absolutely normal
that's right
we are rewriting history because this
year has been a year of shut up
the payback year for you this is so
let's go lisa
the pixel counting fun stuff that we
were doing
so hey like i said you did say obviously
we respect with digital foundation but
we do see it is you know i've seen a
couple of yours it was pretty impressive
i believe the uh miles morales one was
pretty cool and i i think recently what
i'm gonna say is a picture cap but you
even put up the um there's the
spider-man in in avengers what's going
on
so that was different that wasn't for
the main channel that was from my little
channel so
my kind of signature for the content is
i'm one of the only people around that
does hdr content i love so every now and
again i just stick something simple up
on my own like throwaway channel and the
spiderman avengers and
miles morales one um remastered whatever
that that wasn't proper content that's
just on my channel and the game on daily
channel some of the technologies ones
that i've done oh
i appreciate it i really did though
thank you
that's when getting exclusive go wrong
oh my god
that's that's spider-man that must have
been one of the multiverse spider-man
spider-man
that's what he said it looked like a
white woman in super class i died i died
they was doing it
when i i knew it was suspect when i saw
the trailer because when i saw the
trailer i was like this spider-man looks
too bulky like spider-man's supposed to
be somewhat gangly like gangly because
you know he's supposed to be there yeah
so when i saw him i'm like he looks like
a bulky dude like
and i'm like he looks like his
movement's going to be stiff and and i
know it's just a trailer but i'm like i
don't know man i like the way that
trailer looked and when i saw it it
reminded you remember the old spider-man
show
we had the wristbands no he's talking
about the electric company
no no it was i forget his name now um
the guy who was
way back
like like 70 spider-man where they when
they use the same the same video for
crawling outside yeah
it reminded me of that i was like no i
can't no
no it can't be you know when it was done
for me
when they said okay there would be no
story content
and just threw them in the background
and the fact that they held on to that
until it launched no one knew that
everybody thought it was going to be
like like a black panther expansion
right and and they got that
yeah i mean i i get it i know this
wasn't a topic but yeah for me it was
the the obviously the animation and then
this suspends this belief with the
swinging
when it was not attaching to anything so
that kind of that was that was ps2
spiderman yeah so it kind of took me out
of it but i want to get back we'll focus
with as far as the
comparison thing like what was your
whole like with hdr content that's why i
really want to focus on that
um yeah so on the main channel the
technologies ones there's some i do like
one of them the spider-man one that you
said um not this recent little
comparison but the mars morales stuff
the gears are four or five stuff and
there's there's a whole video on how the
the two consoles handle hdr and that
compact content
that kind of stuff i love doing stuff
that i hate doing is like
the stuff that king loves where you came
comparing them but it
brings so much
fire in the way that i don't know
yeah and people yes the fanboy this yes
that's okay
isn't that some of your best view oh my
god
you know your scary stuff is best for me
i don't care because your vr stuff is
best for me
you're not wrong though but i have to
say that like yes best viewed content
and i still am not doing it wherever
possible
like these direct comparisons because
some things aren't aren't worth the
views
i feel and at the end of the day you
know you ultimately have to do what you
enjoy doing you know i'm saying that
that's number one and you know to your
point where i do kind of agree with you
and solve on this one is that look we
respect the guys at digital foundry we
had john lennon in the realm before
great guy i love those guys
i love it when it benefits me
i watch the video and if it says well
you know xbox is having a little hiccup
you two down yeah
okay i got you but uh no i mean i
totally understand i think for me
after a while you know i kind of got
disinterested because again there's that
fine line i think you actually said it
well which is like
yes if you do that content you know
it's going to drive a lot of traffic a
lot of people are going to tune in based
on their platform of choice and it's
going to incite a certain type of um
viewer and it's it's the flip side of it
was like look i kind of enjoy like what
you're saying like i kind of enjoy
seeing the hdr content other aspects of
lighting and things that's going on in
the game and that excites you so i
respect that because it would be very
easy for you because of your tech
background the way you analyze very
eloquently
if you did that that is literally a free
lane for content and viewership to
compare this vlog
[Laughter]
teach me how to do it if you don't want
to do it just slide that over here oh my
god i can't make sure i pick out those
games that make my console
yeah anyway
you remember our hdr battle from a
couple of years back yes wait wait the
the gears of hdr value oh yo we got so
many people
in on that combo it was so [ __ ] me no
this one's better no this was better and
it was like
yes smoke smoke brings the the smoke
brings guys
shout out to lord asap for walking the
holy path that
is
for content creators sometimes people
chase the carrot yeah yeah right and
to have integrity to say you know i know
like you you i if i do this this will
actually bring a ton of views yeah and
sometimes
like all money ain't good money all
factors try to tell that to people you
know um
you have to be you have to have some
form of integrity you have to stand
behind whatever you believe in and if
you know something is purposely going to
either hurt someone or or or just just
you know the comments you see the
comments in the bottom of the video you
don't want to be associated with that so
a lot of stuff i don't tweet out or i
won't put a like to on certain things
because i feel that it drives a certain
level of content that i don't want now
some stuff is
and fun
but again it's it's great integrity on
yourself fair enough i wanted to also
talk about your passion which is new for
me and this is where you and king are
really in pocket is your passion for vr
i'm a late comer you know what i mean i
was i was a hater i was the one i'd
never do that's goofy and you know i
didn't go up front you know after
getting the quest to you know
i really started to enjoy it i really
thought
yeah i definitely didn't want it because
what it is
you know what it was king
for me my debut no it definitely fought
alert on me definitely for a lot of me
yeah fro
all right let me let me let me tell you
what this fraud is about
here we go i'm sitting here i brought my
playstation vr i'm knee-deep in in vr
right um and also you know the vive uh
i'm knee deep in this stuff i'm loving
it
i'm telling him yo god man you got nah
man yo [ __ ] man you really nah man
you'll stop bothering me with that so we
get the packs
and he didn't uh do the vr correct we
got attic to do it yes right
so attic is a very particular dude but
attic had some fun with it right he
actually put it on had some fun with it
i don't know what possessed this man get
this vr
what he did
and he had to put out his tweet
and i screenshot it and i see him i put
it in a special folder because this is
the day the knees were bent
i always admit you know what i said i
was definitely hating on it for me
you know when i get to you aside but for
me it was just like my early experience
was like the the samsung gear
you know i said like some very
rudimentary
experience and then i'm not gonna lie
like there was the you know what they
did it for me king to part well i
couldn't but it was my ego
because i remember sorry i think you
remember it was the new york times
and they had it it was palmer lucky yeah
and he had a chest out
about that he was business
and i was like i didn't want to be
associated with that at the time like
the coolness
i try to keep a cool level to the game
like we geeks
boy cold right so that wasn't cool to me
so i was hating right but i'm not going
full circle though
seeing a half-life alex
seeing demo like seeing
what virtual reality can do
like it was absolutely amazing oh shout
out to addict i pulled up it was
absolutely amazing to me and then just
the quest demo
and and manipulating the objects and in
the 3d space i'm like
okay yeah i was wrong this is fire but
asa tell me why you're so passionate
about vr
uh those same reasons and
it's just it's a it's
a different level of gaming it's a
different level of interactivity and the
things that you can do in vr um
when you start seeing games from that
perspective where you expect things to
be interactive in a certain way where
you see something and you're like oh i
need to put that in my inventory you
pick it up and you stick at your back
that's completely different you hear
people talk about
what's better for like halo is it better
to end with a keyboard and mouse and a
controller and that's a fair
conversation but it's completely
different ball game uh pointing a gun
which is what you do in vr right it's
like
it's incredible um
and you know i said i don't do portable
gaming because i'd be sick if i do it
like with any kind of emotion right i'm
one of these people that suffers quite a
lot of motion sickness so vr for me all
of these people that are saying it's
never going to get anywhere it makes you
nauseous that was a pretty big battle
for me because it definitely made me
nauseous but i just
i love it so much that i've learned the
ways around it and
i know what movements are going to make
me sick and playstation vr unfortunately
is going to make me sick every time
because of its camera restriction
and
that literally sounds like a domestic
relationship i know it's going to make
me
[Music]
i'm on medication i'm almost
[Applause]
if you don't know there's a green screen
here and i'm really over there and this
is just this is a video
you're ridiculous yeah real quick we
said we were just talking before about
uh like tech stuff and whatnot um just
be prepared for a little smoke because
um playstation just announced oh gran
turismo 7 will be out on march 4th right
so the video they're showing has uh the
foliage there's some popping happening
in the video they're going home
there are already comments flying about
yeah so over there so they're already
going in on how it looks yeah yeah i got
it i got to see it
[Laughter]
back on focus i want to get this his
bars off his final question again you
would say with the vr going through the
books of sickness doing all like and
still give me some standout games for
you
yeah so i mean i'll say what vr headsets
i've got or i've had so i started with
the oculus rift the first one i've got i
had um the samsung odyssey windows mixed
reality headset oh wow i have an oculus
quest 2 and i've got a reverb gt which
is another windows mixed reality headset
so
so i'm very well versed in what
microsoft's doing to do and don't do
with vr all right
including not doing forza horizon yes
come on no it does scream it it does
screw it
definitely does and so did the previous
one
um but yeah um stand up guys been half
life alex walking dead saints and
sinners are incredible games
i remember the first game that i played
in vr was table tennis and i had a few
rounds of table tennis and then i went
to put the connection
exhausting
table tennis that seems exhausting
like i'm i'm i'm like i'm like
hyperventilating just thinking about her
you are medication
medications
continue i'm not medication
yeah you put the table tennis
i put the controller on the table tennis
table which wasn't real right it's a
virtual reality table so i just dropped
it on the floor day one of owning this
thing like oh yeah
the pass through since you're able to
see uh you know like
that you don't know time for that no
time for that i've got the boundary set
up so i can warn you but okay yeah i
don't use that you just use the boundary
so you you mark your play area and then
you don't you don't want to break
immersion
um
it's it's not actually that convenient
to bring up the second year on most of
the headsets okay i don't want to pause
and have a look um
fair enough
plus if i have a tiny gap i can kind of
see where the walls are
you leave that gap underneath the doors
oh i definitely would like i've hit
doors and walls plenty and
that skyrim poster that is because i
will probably be playing skyrim until i
die but it is not the anniversary
edition it's the vr edition
okay
which you see them dragons properly
right always different you know what i
got to try
how do they handle the motion is it are
you just sort of like uh like
teleporting place to place
you can see on skyrim you can choose you
can teleport from place to place or you
can use the sticks to move um okay and
it's well worth like obviously the pc
version you can mod the high heavens and
you can use all of the skyrim special
edition mods and those vr specific mods
and you can make it whatever you want it
to be um
do you ever want to go so hardcore to
get like the
i was going sort of old the treadmill
the treadmill
the treadmills don't work or i would
love to no no
yeah their their practicalities are
pretty pretty complicated actually like
moving away that's remotely natural
um
otherwise i'd love to and i'm really i'm
really looking forward to the
playstation brt i think that will
be on a different level to the
playstation vr by a long shot and not
just because the playstation
how do you feel about it being tethered
i don't think it will be i mean i know
it will be but i think there'll be a
wireless accessory a wire a wireless
battery pack thing i think it's because
that keeps the price down okay and i
think you'll be able to opt out okay
yeah that would be great because at the
end of the day yeah you want it you want
like i'm with king that you do want to
be separate from it so but i see what
you put from a practicality standpoint
yeah they probably would do that so do
you think it's not
it's going to give you the option to to
you use ps5 power and then when it's
untethered not so it'll be no i don't
think it i don't think it'll stand alone
i just think um because the playstation
5's got on wi-fi six right i think
specifically for vr and i could be wrong
like this is definitely nothing it seems
right because my
when when it was like
the uh the wi-fi six i thought at the
time that seemed a little overkill and
then if that now that you say that that
makes a lot of sense why they would put
wi-fi six in that yep that's actually a
huge event that's actually advantage
that they have with wi-fi
especially if they're doing vr and
microsoft isn't yeah correct continuous
that's right continuation
yeah um so that's my hype like i said
don't do that i'll be disappointed but i
am quite used to cable management now
because the the reverb gt is the river
g2 by the way and the screens on there
if you're used to vr with like screen
door gaps and things
yeah no doubt i absolutely know it's
like looking at monasteries
that's great
absolutely yeah um
i was gonna say i wouldn't break
protocol just for a second saw what
can't get my brother ksit file super
chat swim to the lords in this and all
this vr talk try some lone echo storm
lands
but i'm sorry the psvr one belongs in
the bushes all right
do you agree with those game choices
yeah fantastic the oculus games and
oculus is a slightly divisive point
facebook and oculus keeping things on
their platform yeah if you've got access
to them yeah
no doubt no doubt and our final question
i have for you i don't we move forward
is uh
balancing the sauce i want to shout out
to a lot of guys you know obviously we
see the videos like gas is outside
literally
you know so it's like again like i said
i just feel you guys have this great
dabbit because it's like you're the
reserve kind of quiet you know technical
person whereas guys is a very
opinionated very very expressive i will
say
you know so like how do you why do you
think it's working as well for you guys
because you guys are really growing man
i'm seeing the the traffic i'm seeing
what you guys are doing you guys have
amazing guests the show is great you
know as far as youtube and stuff like
that and obviously you guys really been
putting out a lot of quality content so
like tell me about that dynamic and that
growth how has it been for you
it's funny i hear that from the outside
a lot that we have this good dynamic
because we're so different and we are
very different and we get along really
well um
most of the time well
i've got like a small pet peeve with him
right now because he's doing a skit i'm
going to let you know secretly he's not
telling people yet but he's doing let's
get this place around the matrix he's
cast himself as neo
not me oh
you supposed to be neal you got the look
the whole yeah that you're supposed to
be there i i agree i'm gonna put the
petition in guys change the sauce up we
know who the real neo is come on now
that's that's an executive decision
you create vehicles for yourself
put himself in the matrix
but when that's not going on we get
along just fine right now we do um
and yeah we've got some different ideas
like he's made he's way more keen on the
youtube stuff
wait a second
are you in it
have you please tell me yeah oh you're
in the sauce
please tell me
can we can we get an exclusive of who
acer is playing in the song
yeah i mean yeah it would be
fairly logical for it like a go and all
the rest of it um i mean to be fair he
is using you so you can't give that
information
[Laughter]
yeah no that would be that would be the
architect have you signed an nda okay
now no no no no that's fine he looks
yeah you know what he does look like the
maravingian yes
he's like the married baby but yeah i'm
gonna tell you this
you're gonna be a fire the architect
that like i can see that explaining all
the possibilities all the oh that's
gonna be fine i like this it's been
years since i've uh since i watched it
that's the dude in like the white
building
and he had the pen and he's going
through the emotion so question is guys
also playing trinity
watching this podcast like i made him
sign an nda
yeah we're sorry guys you bro we broke
the nba we getting all the swords all
right we're getting it all but look man
[Music]
yeah that's us like we did get along
outside of it um we would play games
together but he's constantly on apex
legends and i don't really do battle
royale particularly um
yeah yeah no salute brother
we love what you're doing like i said
tremendous game history love what's
going on i loved it
you got to watch this show when he gets
to the nintendo 64. i've been watching
it yeah
yeah he's got a slap yeah so what did
you feel about the nintendo switch i
mean the zelda the zelda slater
specifically i mean it is what it is you
know some people think they're right but
most of the time they're not i mean he
didn't
he didn't slander zelda he said he
should have played it oh yeah yeah he's
slandered mario yeah he said it man
okay i didn't see i didn't see that part
i'm okay with the mario slander
he says because of mario he chose not to
delve into zelda and that was a mistake
that was that was a mistake
but don't don't if you do get into it
don't put don't start it with um
skyward sword i mean that's kind of
sword
don't start with breath of the wild
anyway oh stop it like skyward i'm sorry
anyway but like i said i love love the
history and again i love what you guys
doing with the site and you know running
an aggregate platform and i'm just
excited to see you guys what it evolves
into and um yeah man like i said i've
used you guys in the past gonna continue
to use it but we gotta use you guys well
i gotta speak to my editorial team we
gotta definitely you know work because
it's about bringing people together on
and and making sure the content creators
the art of journalists they're getting
their their shine you know and i like i
like what you're doing and the intention
behind it so i gotta ask you a question
no doubt that uh we ask all those in the
realm lord ace you know what's coming
because you've been watching the show i
need your top five video games or
franchises of all time
i really should have planned this in
advance you're right i do know that you
ask this question all the time um
halo oh hands drinking saga
your lifetime guest was solved i don't
want to say this because you'll ask the
follow-up question but mass effect i
know what's coming
i know it's coming
let's see who sides you're you're a soft
side on your my side
as in i'm right they're wrong
which vast effect is lord ace's favorite
mass effect
keep in mind cognito has his hands
straight over the eject button
i think i know where he's going i think
i know he's gone
he's going to say the truth
yeah i know it i knew it i knew him i do
it i do it
one was like
out on a limb something new something
incredible like the start of the
franchise and i respect it massively and
three
if you scrap the ending what's the best
as a three game oh you might go addict
he said one versus three i said yeah
it's three it's three
three is only as good because one and
two set up
three as well as it did like they're
literally the entire franchise because i
played them back to back i didn't wait
no years like you guys did
so like the only reason
the only reason three was this so
just give me five seconds yeah
i would already be done with this if you
wouldn't have interrupted me now all i
was gonna say is the only reason three
is as great as it is is because of the
story building that they like the stuff
that you was like oh i can't wait to see
how that resolves that's in three yeah
that absolutely it's back to back
again halo dope from passing dragon saga
then we got mass effect three and now we
got two more
you know i will say as well if you ask
me this on a different day you'll get
different answers i am like
thinking of these other games
sonic's not on it
[Music]
all right i have that poster because
it's the first game that i fell in love
with but it does not land on the list
okay
final fantasy vii does my man are we
back we back baby
we back baby talk tell them about that
influence tell them about that
tell them why i want to hear an
explanation
and it is it's seven specifically as
well it's not final fantasy as a
franchise yeah seven specifically
i don't know what to say about it is it
like the remake as well the original and
the remake oh what they've done of it i
adored them both yes um
that's one of the first games that i
used to stay up until like four in the
morning when i had school a few hours
later just playing that just playing and
doing every little detail on it
and i was i was just hooked on that one
so
one more time
to change role-playing games yeah yeah
it did it did it made it mainstream too
you know what i'm saying i would say
that but yeah brought him out of the
dungeons yeah no longer were you you
know the geeky dude
final fantasy 7
made rpgs cool yes
i would say that i would say that so one
more one more so many that i could put
in this last lot i'm going to say
i'm going to go with quake
first three tell us i mean he's gonna
say that because of the pc lineage yeah
these dudes really don't understand well
uh sovereign knows um
how influential quake was yep quake made
people buy pcs
like quake made people
really respect the pc uh uh gaming space
because like he said
you were on 30 frames per second and he
was out here moving
so uh it really brought that fast-paced
feel to it it was a little bit different
than doom because of the polygons and
all the textures and stuff that was
going on it really pushed the genre
forward it was a really influential game
and you mean so and i mean if you're
talking about arena right it's
it's that gets
it's just a multiplayer game so this is
the one that really like it was there
was no story it was just get in there
and kill
and it moves so quickly like it like to
king's point yeah
it made you go out there and look at
those those those gfx cars like hmm
those voodoo cars like hmm
how do i get my hands on one of those oh
quake is special yeah very specific i
have to i have to list it it's funny
because um so quake made me buy a
keyboard and mouse for the dreamcast
first of all and then it let me buy the
whole pc and go all in and play so much
of it and you have all this conversation
around halo right now and how good or
bad the progression system is the
progression system on kuwait was you
just you get better at it
i do want to address that real quick
like like look man if there's any halo
fans in here that's up on that reddick
like i get it like i'm myself i'm one of
those people it's like you know they got
stuff to improve on it's like
come on let let's calm things down man
because they had to shut down the halo
reddick because it was getting so toxic
like yeah it's great let's calm that
down
tremendous tremendous history brother um
love the five
and favorite console of all time no we
know you like pc but we gotta ask your
favorite console of all time any
generation and why
raincoast oh
with confidence you said that quick
there was no hesitation on that
i very quickly scanned over the history
that i gave you just now
and fantasy star online and quake three
are two of the most like influential in
my history of gaming and that they
pushed me in new directions in gaming
and
what dreamcast did despite its like
short life and all the rest of it it was
pushing things in a direction that i
love yeah yeah every i think
sega fans would agree you know and um
i mean the dreamcast was special let's
just call it for what it was
at the time and again the great peter
moore it was just it was a beautiful
time man and the launch line up
tremendous yeah i can't talk your talk i
see you no no no i was just happy that
microsoft hadn't handed it oh yeah
myself see it was the os you know what i
said you know they talked about that
when they had that little round table
there and they expressed that they
always had some type of dealings with
each other
and i don't care what anybody say you
know we probably never ever wanted
microsoft to jump into that space but
they are the spiritual successor to what
we had uh left the remnants of that uh
so that bare bones
you're still on medication that's the
medication
now that
like a lot of times people was like oh i
had windows ce and people don't really
know what that means right but
we when we talk about it like windows ce
was a completely different development
platform that allowed the dreamcast to
port certain games that just the other
consoles couldn't do right
so it was like it was literally two
separate development platforms for this
one console and
that allowed when you look at the you
see a lot of great arcade ports right
but then
a little bit later in its life cycle
which is very short but you started
seeing you know where they could push
the console quote unquote console gaming
um yeah i just love the freaking
dreamcast and it's so sad
it's just amazing
yeah absolutely man
lord acer hanging out still rocking out
with us right we got some topics to get
into salute you know what i'm saying so
i know you're getting queue up the super
chats i am going to um start the poll
while you do that yeah do that because i
i'm ready to go but go ahead no doubt no
doubt so let's
[Laughter]
do you want me to send the invite things
um
actually hold off for a second because
we got a lot of those for one second but
um yeah so last week's poll results are
in and the people have spoken with the
recent success of halo infinite's
multiplayer beta gameplay and engagement
which core problem do you think 343
needs to address first the winner of a
kind of semi-close four-way ilp poll at
58 of the vote was the progression
system doesn't reward objective play in
kill streaks enough group coming in at
second at 23 percent of the vote was the
dedicated playlist and on an optional
unranked cross-play group
in third place at 13 of the vote was the
messy lords i don't care i'm spending my
whole check for pvp suit
and his last place and only four percent
of the vote was not enough free to play
quality cosmetic content that shouldn't
be time gated so salute to all the lords
lord attic i believe this is your you
won this is the one you were shouting
from the hill as far as the objective
and stuff your thoughts sir
i just you know i do feel like they've
done enough to keep me satisfied until
the new year but it's just like look
like yeah
somebody's working for you yeah i
well i was going to say to someone else
by halo but it's free
at the end of the day like
we we got it's like i said earlier we
got to relax on the 343 stuff like
i do feel like they they have done
they've over
shot with xp at this point like i'm
leveling up five six times a day now
yeah so it's just like look this is good
enough to give people that xp that they
crave until next year when they could
come back refreshed and less stressed
and and and tackle it with a permanent
solution
no doubt no doubt solve you want to get
the uh super chat edition yeah let me
copy paste these last couple ones that
came in
and then i will go back
actually before i read the super chats i
want to give a big shout out
to
our friend in the realm oh drunken ninja
new new york's it comes up is it drunken
ninja because it comes up new york's
finest okay right
so
um yeah so sincerely wmd has
alias new york's finest i don't know if
it's drunk in ninja if it is thank you
brother um he's
giving the realm a
14-day game pass that's got to be
yeah yeah so um so i'm going to drop
that in the chat right now um
obviously probably most people in the
chat probably have game pass or are in
the xbox ecosystem already but uh there
are a lot of new uh there are a lot of
new little mans out there so maybe man
that's for christopher hart
should i just dm it to christopher hart
as you say
man come over here and partake
let me let me drop this in the chat
because i had to copy and paste a couple
of other things somebody give him some
mashed potatoes
[Laughter]
[Music]
shout out to new york's finest
sincerely wmd thank you so much and if
it's drunken ninja i don't know
you're completely different on twitter
so uh
so back okay let me get into these super
chats
why are you doing that um
what's gonna say let me um make sure
that i got the drip real quick i'll take
care of that real quick if you're still
working no no go ahead go ahead um yeah
we got pilo three one eight he got the
classic all natty hold on
got the all
he said long time listener second time
purchaser please keep up with the great
work thank you so much
and when you play in that fable two put
that all nadio
got that all daddy t i see you reppin
the cake no doubt no doubt guess what
all right cool hold on a second
so first off we have shroom kingdom five
dollar super chat jim must have seen
jamaican gym then he started working on
spartacus to come for a railing
yeah we all know what happens to
spartacus
i think i'll get to it there we go
raider blade remember for eight ten
months thank you sir
uh king i believe you might be right
that this is sony's last console if xbox
acquires another big publisher sony
might go third party
they will you'll see sparta kiss
with the 40 rupee super chat absolute
no ps now in india yet no expectation
for spartacus okay
he's got his opinions
then we have capital dream 20 of a chat
the narrative that these sony folks are
putting out there that they don't want a
game pass like service is full the
service is not provided to you so you
damage so you can damage control that's
right if it was available you'll be on
it like a fat boy cake wow
well popeyes biscuits
king your loyal subject asa is trying to
relay his story have patience to hear
him out yeah
you try to erase the xbox whatever
that's what that was yeah
[Music]
me and you would get along great i got
no love for portable consoles outside of
my cell phone and that's for b and
that's for bs so what's bs all right
whatever
64 and that controller was trashed to me
as well
two days to halo i and and destiny on
the 30th mm-hmm absolutely that that was
a horrible controller it was a unique
controller but it was horrible it was it
was built for mario that's it
real quick see the legendary lord
flemish how are you doing sir
what's going on brother how you doing
you want to hear your levels well make
sure you go
there yeah can you hear me yes sorry
don't we hear you brother we hear you
man good to make it thank thank you for
making it you don't say it we'll get it
till you're gonna finish these super
chats we got a lot to talk about but
okay so
then we have hard to find remember for
eight months two thirds of the year with
my guys love y'all and definitely here
for the nintendo diss album going on
there we have black ronin five dollars
super chat uh okay
we thank you black ronin we're not gonna
address this until it becomes yeah
official news when it becomes official
news we'll have things to say about it
but not not yet
um and we have matt tichbon 10 pounds
super chat great seeing ace in the realm
uk representing got my popcorn from when
we get spartacus this isn't a game fast
copy sony's taking a leap from
nintendo's book charging folks extra for
back come back
it's all like donkey kong and i said
that too
[Music]
97 right
was it 97
all the time right yes 97
right
damage
then we got relish gt five dollar super
chat can you imagine if halo and the
connect would have been beautiful uh vr
without the motion sickness xbox one
dropped the ball with the connect
you said xbox one or donny
[Laughter]
we're going to do that salon 7 the
darkness remember for 12 months hit the
like button for this fire stream thank
you sir mm-hmm
there we have ethanol sandwich again
five dollars with a chat peace to the
lords of the realm of salute blessings
then we have lord metroid member for
three months king disrespecting my
beloved metroid series while skyward
sword is the game he should be throwing
into the bush you're glad to be part of
iov cheers
but what's gonna happen is
what has always happened to metroid
it's going to show up last no i didn't
know there was this hateful message i
learned about this
right yeah actually it's actually fun
news so like when you you know you found
out something you like wow really he
doesn't even get a chance to get a plate
inside the house i'm done detroit eats
outside on the porch
wow
good and we have splendiferous
two dollar super chat attic looked like
he was just yanking ace's chain n64
wow
i don't know
look i i feel like you shouldn't be
imagining me doing anything in your mind
particularly
[Laughter]
then we have tony bryant member for 17
months thank you sir great to be here
live again great time to be a gamer
kefka is goat by the way yes he is cog
reigning your damn drivatar tired of
getting passed at the end
at least he's passing people again
you're not murdering them you know
you're in the way
then we have oh thank you brother shark
in a chair hundred dollar super chat
thank you just wanted to give something
for you all live been in the hospital
for about a month oh my goodness all
right
liver surgery i hope you're doing better
sir appreciate it thank you
and i've been watching about all of your
podcast bits like 200 of them love the
show don't ever stop wow thank you so
much food
them four hours with you a whole month
one thing the lord will give you is a
lot of content yeah yeah but but please
don't bust the gut laughs
salute to him and that that is that's
humbling seeing someone listening to
yeah
do something absolutely definitely hope
you get better man
um don't otaku five dollar super chat
cog and maddie ran from the pslander and
defining duke with my with my writing
this week so i'm gonna need extra
slander from king and addict today
hashtag the book of days yeah i saw that
writing
yeah i saw what you tried doing dude
salute to you though
and we got corey hale member for 18
months anyone played chorus
not yet not yet
we we do have a review on laura
though
that's right go check that i'll go to
lords of gabriel.net check that out it
is up right now so you can find all the
details on court and then
find me in six months when it comes to
game pass and i'll give you another
review
and also keep in mind uh
i don't know if i'm allowed to say so
i'm not going to say it but in the next
couple days
there's going to be a review on the on
the iron lord's podcast channel so
definitely uh look at that yes yes yes
what could it be we don't know but we're
going to move on
uh put the crust in the chat for the
newest member of the realm cerebral
palsy thank you sir for gold
right then we have
spotlight gopz with the 1.79 pounds
super chat
will jamaican ryan beyonce
uh unfortunately
[Laughter]
unfortunately jamaica and jim ryan got a
lot of thing to do
then we have the wise old gamer five
dollars in chat speak for yourself my
wife loves the n64 controller especially
with rumble pack attacks
brother you get this
wow wow
then we have lord roughness the
firepower super jacket
so he's so desperate for mines are out
here talking spartacus but showing no
value anywhere near the mighty game past
and still no day and date
not yet
then we have yodani quesada five dollar
super chat hope y'all know the heimlich
for ps bros cause the popeye's biscuits
are a choking hazard
my boys are thirsty for game pass it's
so dry
it's a metaphor it's a metaphor you guys
are
you guys are being real extra in this
they clearly couldn't wait for one topic
you need to get the church's biscuits
with the honey those those are those
then we got cerebral palsy once again
2010 happy holidays lord same to you so
happy holidays
then we have you cannot defeat my state
and style let's put the crust in the
chat right there as a member of the
realm dangerous style i like that that's
fine
and by the way uh i will be streaming
shinobi tomorrow at 6 00 p.m
thank you sir
on the real difficulties not that right
crazy
the crazy thing is that he actually got
pretty decent for our entity that's
what's up right okay what we got real
hard the wise old gamer five dollars if
you chat somebody's going to rebrand ps
now and sell it as a new ps plus just
like they take just like they take their
games and re-skin them as either the
last of us goes to tsushima
et cetera
so messy and we have alex escorts a
member for four months thank you sir
playstation fans stay buying your games
you want to support the deaths right
you knew that was good
and i believe no we we're not cool we
got more goodness
okay we have splendifer
five dollar super chat correction
not imagining him yanking aces chain
pause in other words pulling his leg
about the mario and zelda yes we know
that's what you meant but you know you
you have to watch how you find it i
don't i don't know how i feel about you
imagining him pulling my leg too so yeah
he's a joke figure of speech he said
he's with asa i know i know
i with asa i'm not interested
okay last one
yes heart get chinese five dollars for a
chat jamaican jim ryan has been attacked
by spartacus or is it the other way
around
far
look baby i think we all caught up on
the super chats again yes we are
up we gotta get into it y'all know what
we're here for
[Laughter]
behold in the arena the gaming
subscription champion has started the
bringer of rain playstation spartacus
has been announced
so i'm going to need some man to set it
up man cause i mean i can set it up if
you want because it's up to you because
i was gonna let you write the topic or i
could set it that way
is it this king's topic well technically
no technically it was kick-ass something
else so we have to set on okay oh okay
you got the next one
so yeah uh so playstation well they
didn't announce shout out to jason
schreiber bloomberg uh got the scoop on
the fact that uh coming this spring is a
quote-unquote game pass competitor
codename spartacus which is
looking to essentially eliminate and the
ps now naming and consolidate ps now
with ps plus and give some semblance of
a subscription service which would uh
be be multi-tiered and give options
uh
assumedly with the highest tier um
crunchyroll
get with the highest tier giving access
to
that compatible that compatibility
beyond just the players okay
okay so you can read it right but if
somebody is reading it to you or you're
listening to it i don't know how anyone
in their camp said that's a good idea
let him finish
the snow get himself
so
so uh at this point the rumor is that
it's going to be multi-tiered with the
initial tier just being playstation plus
right no addition
the t the second tier will will give you
ps4 games and eventually
games
and the third tier will offer you and i
quote extended demos
and a library of playstation 1
playstation 2 playstation 3 and psp
games yes i gotta go first
clearly you want to talk
the vita has once again been been
ostracized from this
so um yeah and there have been there's
been some conversation around yes um as
to how it compares and does not compare
favorably or otherwise
to game pass so um
i'll turn it over let's turn it over
literally they say okay so we're gonna
give you the same thing that you got
ready
and we're gonna have stair steps to this
joint he said so like y'all like back to
pack your song real what i told you
they're gonna make you pay for it oh fat
king is a prophet on that one king is a
problem
[Laughter]
they said microsoft giving it for free
[Laughter]
not us let me show you how we get this
boat oh
my god yo this has got to i don't know
who's sitting in these meetings but it's
showing somebody looking out for the
consumer
i thought absolutely crazy yo they said
a competitor
[Laughter]
okay
you're in these corporate meetings and
they ask you they're like king hey
so no no no no king what what could we
do to improve our service
okay so okay
they really asked me this question right
copy exactly what you see over there
put the consumer first
get a solution for backup make that free
we already know that playstation now is
a failure right so take the playstation
plus subscription and and and put that
together with the playstation now right
right and and actually we gotta put
yeah put crunchyroll and all your
animation stuff
into this package
charge an extra three four bucks
whatever you're gonna do
but
show some value
there is no value here
and if you're going to make it tears
and say
one of these tears
you get a chance to play playstation 1
in playstation 2
and they're not extensively present to
be the highest here that's the crazy
thing about it it's the highest this
year
just to clarify though king
weren't you the same person yesterday
for uh last week saying that if you want
stuff like like cosmetics and halo and
you want that premium experience that
you just got to pay that money
yes sir
so what is it how does so so how does
this is different this is not the
premium
experience this explain what show me
anywhere here that says this is premium
i don't hear please
so just to clarify
buying cosmetics that have no value
whatsoever in halo
that's that's not that's a dream
experience look at that
so so so drip is premium experience
right physical games that you can play
isn't it no not games at 25 frames per
second and you ain't enhancing anything
no
no no games that i played see this has
value for somebody that wants to be
nostalgic right
that doesn't want to go out and get a
playstation 1 or a playstation 2 and
wants to play these games in their
original form the ones that jim said
they are ugly that nobody wants to play
these games
this is mixed messaging here
all right so you set your your fan base
up to believe one thing right
you said subscription services can't
sustain itself
you said these things aren't profitable
he is right there right he is right
yeah
the way that we're doing things is
profitable for our company
but then you look over at your man's
boat and say
yo
where did he get this boat okay are you
wrong king are you implying that the
leader is why is the leader looking at
i told you from day one he was complicit
right so i told you don't believe
anything that he's that's being said i
told you that you're gonna have a game
pass situation later on but this is not
it
like
when you don't put your premier consoles
games into your subscription service
this is not premium
right i mean you have a playstation 5
but then you got the subscription
service with no playstation 5 games
what are you doing so absolutely this is
a fail and i know that they're going to
hear about it and hopefully they're as
as quick as um xbox is to fix uh stuff
fix verbiage uh make it right just you
don't have to do date and date okay
right what's the change for you but no
no no i'm i'm baby steps with these
dudes okay because obviously they can't
get this carrot right anyway so what i
what i would say is
these games that have initially launched
on the playstation 5 in the beginning
let's start moving it forward to
first tier games playstation 5 games put
it in the service right and then get to
the next six months and bring those
games in
if you want to still worry about the
metrics the old metrics but
i don't see the value and maybe i'm
wrong maybe i'm just fan going out and
i'm laughing too hard because they seem
to be stepping on rakes everywhere they
go
but i don't see playstation five games
there before that's mine before i open
it up to asa and flemish i do want to
ask you you know i agree with you on the
part where you're talking about i know
you're going with playstation now right
and and then you know the the user base
and they're not really be the success
and you know but what about just from
the consolidation standpoint like does
that
that part to you still have no value
because obviously playstation i believe
they brought the price down at one point
and then obviously playstation plus
which is doing well for them and i
believe they have the collection series
whatever so even the consolidation you
still feel is no va not a lot of value
or is it you're just looking at it
directly compared to game pass
there's a reason why microsoft never got
rid of xbox live
and put it inside game pass
right and just get rid of it right
it's um it's antiquated
in in its state so they're probably
waiting for a a time to just completely
phase it out right but they don't want
to do that to
the existing consumers of that product
it's a lot of money right
so what sony is doing is looking at two
failed projects
and merging two failures on top of each
other so
so we're saying playstation plus is
there's a difference between voicing an
opinion and try to make it a fact my
voice opinions you're trying to make a
penny
i can tell you a fact i don't have it
so in this fact i don't see value right
so i saw value in getting it dripping
halo wait wait why you don't see value
in ps plus i'm curious come on man
stop okay that's a whole different go
ahead guys
i need to know why
i don't feel safe there
oh my god okay let's let's give you the
buck how many people on this panel have
their credit card on their playstation
5. i don't i don't i got paypal
thank you
so this is the safety of this issue for
you
it's a big problem
he's afraid for the children
where the kid with the students walk
around with guns you have to go to
school like that you ain't going to
clubs where there's no security so let's
let's stop acting like security is not a
[ __ ] a1 important thing that is come
on
i will
i will i will agree with him that you
know maybe he does got a point there if
you don't even feel comfortable
purchasing stuff on the on the the
ecosystem then maybe there is something
there but like we can't act like you
know
there isn't an option that you could do
such as something like paypal
is a safety concern
i don't have a safety issue here so so
do you never buy anything on playstation
i did and i'm locked out of my
playstation right now at this moment do
you understand what my frustration with
these dudes are it's a literal problem
with these guys i have a real problem
with the only two games i brought
digital from the playstation 5 for the
playstation 4
is a lot away because they say oh that
email doesn't mean that's the only email
i use with you guys i don't trust you
it's my name
xbox 360 lover 01.
oh so you say you're being discriminated
against because you don't have a ball
game so this is a vendetta against sony
security against you based on your name
basically you're the playstation name
okay you ever try to put xbox in on your
playstation you know how it all
dramatically ends it puts the the word
there yeah
so you're so you're saying playstation
doesn't even have xbox in a system
he's being censored he's be okay we got
it we got it okay
okay let's open this up let's open this
this is a good one let's throw a little
acer first um they said you know
obviously we we talked about this in the
dms this would be a very spicy topic
let's get your perspective you know
playstation spartacus what are you
thinking about it and then change
this definitely feels like they listen
to i love podcasts well we came up with
this code there i i have to say that
what's the name of the the new thing
spartacus
i have to give us a little credit the
lord's got to get a little credit here
but i want to say again playstation is
like what what are you feeling and then
this whole thing and jason tries to
report as they are looking to position
this as a rival for game pass so lord
they see your thoughts please
my cheeks are from
smiling
first of all playstation plus being a
failure right playstation plus game plus
and playstation now the most profitable
of those services is playstation plus
it's got the most subscribers and i put
the least money into it right so that's
not a failure of a service as far as
sony are concerned um
jim ryan told us he was doing this yeah
and i'm not saying you should always
trust jim ryan right but he came out and
said we are
building a service and we'll have news
to announce before long at least they've
not announced it jason's right he's like
giving us a scoop on it and let us know
what's going on but we knew it was
coming and we said at the time like you
look at the way that sony are handling
their two services playstation plus and
playstation now all of their focus is on
playstation plus right since the
playstation 5 has come out
ps now has had some playstation 4 games
and they had a playstation 5 game every
month and playstation plus there's
features of the playstation 5 dashboard
and software that are locked behind
playstation plus and their focus has
been
getting their users
wait wait wait wait wait yeah you know
you talk really fast what did you just
say did you just say
features
playstation 5 beyond just online
multiplayer there are features of the
dashboard
that are locked behind playstation plus
right which starts yeah like cloud um
cloud saving and stuff
yeah and the guides um i think some
games have like um native video guides
and things your audio was crackling a
little bit i was ready to tell you yeah
yeah and you know what's funny i feel
like
no one ever said no one ever says
anything about playstation locking down
cloud saves behind a paywall like like
they attacked nintendo for it remember
but everyone just acts like that doesn't
happen on playstation
continues i wanted to get you continue
your analysis he's a microphone anybody
oh yes yes yes
okay sorry about that um
yeah so
it was obvious at the time that their
focus was going to be playstation plus
there was there's a thing they could do
they could on playstation now they could
very easily rival game pass by changing
the content that's on that service all
right if sony were to say we're going to
put our games in there that's a
different conversation but playstation
now is just not what they're interested
in and the other thing that i have
always said was more likely is they're
going to expand on what they're doing
with playstation plus and they're going
to expand on this playstation collection
they're going to add more games they've
come out now so there's going to be a
three-tiered service right game pass is
a two-tiered service so it's not it's
not massively different already from the
from the get-go
um but the big questions on it for me
firstly the obvious one like what
content am i putting in these three
tiers that's very speculative in the
scoop yeah um so what content is there
what playstation 5 games are there going
to be but the other one the service
battle in general and this is for
microsoft as well as sony the battle for
these services is to expand beyond the
console and that's something that came
past oh you're talking now
yeah but it's something that
right gamepl and they've got a ways to
go so that battle is wide open
and if sony are coming in and they're
rebranding playstation plus but they're
still twisting people's arms they're
still locking features behind me so you
have to get a certain level of that
subscription they do have a very good
base on their console to build on and to
expand beyond that beyond that space so
see what the emphasis is in terms of um
so jason schroeder i didn't mention
there's more of an emphasis on cloud
streaming now like they are trying to
improve what they've got there right
that's a big play so we'll see what that
is
but it's a big play
you got the answers let me ask you this
one before i open it up the flammage
because you've been patient um i wanted
to ask you in reference to the whole one
of the things we see online with this
whole you know announcement reveal rumor
right that we're gonna say if it's triad
we know it's official shout out to jason
tries reporting but um
is the whole concept of day and date
and i want to get from you asa like
do you think
they will
and or do you think you know do they
need to i'm very curious about that
because a lot of people feel that may
need to happen or may not need that but
what's your stance on that what day and
date
not soon for their temple franchises
okay not soon i'm definitely not saying
never like a few years a number of years
down the line
things will change their whole paradigm
will change
but for now now using those those
consoles to bring people onto the
playstation 5 specifically
is what's driving them and all these all
of these big executives so not just
playstation but take two and the rest of
them as well that say it's not
sustainable for us to put our big games
into those services
they're not blowing smoke because they
believe that okay so budgets will change
it's only when sony moved to and we know
that they are doing this but it's only
when it's only moved to really
further monetizing their games that
they'll start putting them in their
services day one gotcha so it won't be a
god of war that's not gone micro
transactions it will be a different kind
of game gotcha okay because they're
model okay i see what you're going to
see i see your thought process lord
flavish making his debut in the realm
great cameo proud member of uh four guys
recorded tv retro renegades you know
what i'm saying flemish xp the positive
gamer podcast you're gonna get a mini
intro god damn it
y'all salute you man you know i've been
trying to get you our schedule is crazy
but i'm glad you can't make this what
you thinking man playstations
what are you feeling
well uh let's first try to compare with
xbox game pass right because that's what
they're trying to do as well so first of
all xbox game pass
microsoft games day and date yeah right
awesome thing
then we got new games that are coming
out day and date just some titles here
and there
um
i
as you see as playstation now is
could they do the same like they
like said before that king said was that
um jim ryan don't think it's profitable
to put the games day and date into game
pass now so
i i think it's a very hard sell and then
put it in tears with ps now on the
highest one right it's only gonna make
it harder to sell it's not gonna make it
easier okay
do you think okay i'm sorry two you
could take please
no no no no i'll ask a question you know
i'm just gonna say that i see where
you're going my question was for you
like
do you think this creates a scenario
where um
they make you feel they may need to add
other things to that higher tier to make
it more attractive because in your base
based on what it sounds like you're
saying is that
we do know playstation now was was not
successful for them they've had it for
maybe six years and you know what is it
three million you know wise king
laughing
but at the end
you know
it's something that you know obviously
they're gonna merge into the service but
like you're saying you're making a
decent point flemish right which is a
lot of the back competitive stuff will
be on that third tier the playstation
psp games ps1 ps2 that kind of thing
let's get laughing so
your opinion that if you feel that
isolates that the playstation now
portion being in the third tier is that
what you're applying
yeah actually i
i think that's the case also i don't see
too many new games like coming to
playstation now at all you don't hear
that talked about it's not in the
conversation like gamepad is everywhere
right i don't see that changing when it
would go into a tv setup i just see it
more dying down
i think playstation plus is where most
people go for yeah and
it seems they're getting a little bit
better with the games they get each
month right i think we we do got some
pro uh
uh yeah ps plus is good yeah player plus
the game is mostly offerings yeah it's
like xbox live yeah yeah it's better
technically what you have to do with
both of those and look at both of the
services combine both and then have a
conversation oh that's what you're doing
now right right right success success
yes
continue flamish sorry if they would put
their
more of their
catalogue that they got now right
from ps5 more into ps now
and then launch it into there and make
it attractive of a good price not too
expensive don't make it 30 bucks a month
because you're gonna you're
probably not to sell
okay it's got to be attractive for the
casuals the casuals the people that play
um the the
console maybe a few times a week maybe
an hour or two
um
those are the ones you're trying to get
to those are the main audience the
they're the most
yeah like
gamers like us
we play all day i mean we're the
hardcore
yeah we we we buy it anyway but we're a
small minority of them so
we we want those
good numbers we want those
of the many no valid valid point i i
hate where you're going with it and um
you know it is going to be key for them
to uh get the casual in into this uh
combination out there kind of
consolidating i want to get attic in
because i know he was he had missed
but um where man what do you think we
didn't get a chance to really talk too
much i think you woke up when the news
broke and i told it to you yeah cog was
like uh the twitter's going crazy i'm
like oh god what happened
i think loki this is a way to
not force people but this is like a way
of them trying to like breathe a little
bit more life into
into the into playstation now i feel
like they know that that was a complete
flop and there's nothing they can do to
breathe life into that so like let's try
something else
and my thing is like the way they're
wording these tears
i mean obviously jason ronald probably
doesn't know 100 of everything i've
always said he's very accurate but
sometimes he does get like little
details wrong
but uh you know i'm curious the biggest
question is like what's the pricing
points right like are they going to
start this at 9.99
14.99 and then 20 dollars like uh
another thing what do you guys think the
odds that within a year year and a half
they put their first party in the
highest tier of whatever they're doing
here that's a good question because to
me having more three tiers yeah that's
pretty hardcore like and everybody was
like oh we're putting fun to made
they're going to put funimation they're
going to put crunchyroll really do you
think they're going to put those in a
gaming service like
yeah
they they're not doing it
disagree they think it's coming they
to me you don't invest into another into
another industry to put it in another
industry like they invested in the anime
culture anime culture because they
wanted to invest in anime culture if
they had intentions on bundling these
services they would have bundled
funimation years ago when they bought
that company but they didn't so you mean
to tell me that they're going to spend
another billion dollars and then bundle
that yeah
they are improving their infrastructure
right yeah well they need to improve
that ui because funimation is dog like
it's horrible
so this is why they won't put it in
there because because okay
no it's horrible it really is like like
crunchyroll is a little bit better but
it's just like look at the end of the
day
i'm just curious why there's three tiers
and then if you read it they're like the
last cheers playstation one two and
three games or something like that psp
so i got a psp i got to play the highest
i got to pay the highest tier to play
old stuff but i thought people didn't
want to play old games
like it's just like sony said like
what's crazy is that like you know what
we
it's crazy because is it a lot of
playstation now back towards games
like ps3 streaming games they have a lot
like they don't have vita games so it's
like so it's like okay what we're going
to do is we're going to we're going to
do a little little witchcraft and put
vida games in here no
actually they're not in there they're
not part of it oh i thought they said
something about all right let's real
quick
yeah the first the first tier the rumor
shout out to jesus
it says the details still may not be
finalized but this is what the
documentation review it is the first
tier would include existing playstation
plus benefits the second would offer a
large catalog of playstation 4 and
eventually playstation 5 games the third
tier so essentially i guess that's the
playstation collection in a sense the
third tier would add extended demos
game streaming
and a library of classic ps1 ps2 ps3 and
psp games not vita vita is not listed
i mean at the end of the day like even
if it's vita like there wasn't like a
lot of top tier vita games there was
good video games but they didn't really
like i it was more like
like kind of what this what nintendo did
with the wii u where they they posted
him like oh
everyone's pirate this stuff so they
didn't really 100 support the video they
did a good job but i don't think there's
anything there that's like so fired that
they want to bring that over
what what's the nintendo's pricing on
their net network that new thing what's
what's their pricing oh you talking
about the the expansion pack is that
what you're talking about yeah what's
what's their pricing it's it's like what
an extra
i think uh
i don't know what what is the price
because i didn't get the top i don't
know
but it's definitely more it was 20 a
year so now i think it's so now it's
closer to 50 years
so that that's my thing it's like if
you're having three
three different forms of this whatever
this is like to me
what what's that second one gonna be
different from the first one
and then what's kind of curious to me
too is like the first one's supposed to
be just plus
yes it's like okay so you go into plus
then you could go upgrade to play some
playstation 4 and 5 games and then you
upgrade again to play some older games
so you needed to tell me
that they're charging you less to play
newer games than they're charging you to
play older games like i'm just like
i i know usually jason ronald is a
hundred percent on
okay
obviously the the a lot of jason's not
my fault jason schreier
i'm he's usually right about everything
i think he's right about this but
there's something about the story that
does not make sense i i don't know what
it is maybe it's jesus no i'm not going
against russian schreier i'm saying that
i don't know if he's got a hundred
percent of all the facts like it makes
no sense to charge more for the older
stuff than a charge for the newer stuff
like that
well that's the thing okay right right
they make it tier three is that in
addition to everything that's in tier
one and tier two right it cannot be okay
no you don't get that other stuff right
so my point is
if you buy tier two you have access to
newer games and then you can upgrade and
play the older games like that
being paid for
right because the back compat is
unfortunately the back compat is is
streaming is streaming right right and
i
i see what lord addict is trying to say
right uh with but
when you think about it everybody wants
to play those new games more that's what
also jim ryan was saying nobody wants to
play those old games
so nobody wants to play those old games
but they're going to charge you more to
play those old games
old games you would put them in the base
subscription service so people would
advocate you gotta admit that's good
business though that's confidence
because he himself don't like it right
so okay okay guess what i don't want to
get it right no he said for sure you're
gonna pay for it right so all right to
me i look at this this
this deal that they're doing whatever
the case may be
and to me it's more optics than anything
else it it is to have
a quote-unquote competitor in the space
that's what i think it is too and it's
just optics to have it
at least at this point right at least at
this point because what they're giving
you is just sort of a realignment of
what they have already and
like alex said they're going to charge
you for things that they haven't
necessarily charged you before before
they're going to consolidate all of that
um i think the ps now name going away
makes 100 sense because
as they as they sort of transition to
whatever
azure backend they're going to have
that's going to improve and you don't
want to you don't want to have that sort
of
hampered by the ps now name you want to
go with the name that's been successful
right so correct
you want to go with that right
so that that makes 100 sense to me um
what
i
you know obviously people the
comparisons the flaming wars about oh a
game passes this this is not anywhere
near where game pass is it will never be
and
well i never say never never say never
but
never but it is right now for what it
for what it's what what what's reporting
there is no there's no way shape or form
they're putting day and date in there
it's just put all right
anytime soon right all right anytime
soon let let me let me say something uh
i was go i was gonna say something but
then call pass my torch to solve for
some reason but uh wait like what time
is it because you you light your torch
everywhere
so
so that that's not happening anytime
soon forget about that right i don't
care that tier 5 is not happening
anytime soon
now the thing about this that's that
really really doesn't even put in the
same league as game pass is the fact
that when you think about where game
pass lives right now
it's not just on the xbox consoles
it's pc right it's
anywhere you can access cloud right so
your phones all this other stuff this is
literally
this isn't even talking about access to
pc games or putting games on a pc this
is literally just talking about the
playstation console ecosystem which is
in comparison to where xbox is is is
living right now is this big right it's
tiny so it doesn't even compare in that
regard and what's sad about this is when
you look like attic was saying when you
looked at tier three right and you
you get and you get the the opportunity
to play ps1 ps2 and ps3 games
when you think about how they approach
back compat
the only issue that they have with back
compat that would require really
streaming is ps3
you know they should you should be able
to download ps1 ps2 psp and ps vita
games with no problem because you've
done it on the vita already you've done
it on the psp already the fact that all
of this is going to be on streaming
and they're going to charge you
what what basically feels like the
highest tier to be able to access it
it's it's egregious it i don't care how
much it costs
it's it's bad business so i whatever the
case may be this is just to create a
talking point hey we have something
right it's but in the at the end of the
day
foreign um
i just wanted to ask though i just want
to state that in schreier's report
yes it states they are planning this
subscription service playstation
audiences two rival microsoft's gaming
so in their mind
this is something that they are looking
at as a competitor to it now one other
question i want to ask you solve is um
we know what playstation now at one
point we know it's the cloud the god kai
stuff right right so we knew about that
initially but
at one point they did evolve it to make
it downloadable right to your case
right so would that would that option
make it more attractive to you in that
sense if they if they brought that as
well well i think they're going to do
that still that's still going to do that
and that's in tier 2 right that's in
tier two what they're talking about in
tier three is the the legacy right the
legacy ps1 ps2 ps3 psp novita um and
like i said ps3
because
because of the the cell processor is the
only one that should that has
classically given them problems in terms
of being able to emulate properly right
right the other ones there should be no
issue
so
it's just
it is that thing like you guys have said
like you guys have a 100 said he doesn't
care about this stuff and if you want it
you're gonna have to pay for it and it's
not and it's not going to be of the
quality that we've come to expect that's
right on other platforms
um
so
to me
like i said it's an optics thing they
hope to they hope to
by by attaching it to ps plus right
their most successful subscription
service i think they think that'll carry
them which is fine which is fine but
when you when you think about the value
there yeah the value just doesn't
compare because at the end of the day
all the trolls around his neck and sync
when you look at game pass right
let's be real you look at game pass
right
200 games you have all these great indie
games whatever
most i'm not gonna say nobody right i
would say most people do not go to game
pass for those games they go to game
pass with the understanding that they're
going to get first party games day and
date right and maybe a year and a half
two years ago that proposition was maybe
a little in
not anymore
now that is the hugest selling point of
this like oh my god i'm getting halo
next week and i'm not paying anything
about extra about it i'm getting game of
the year for the horizon five i'm not
paying extra for it
they have nothing they have nothing on
the playstation side to really combat
that numbers off like i said was saying
like all the numbers like playstations
i'm not saying i'm not saying it won't
be so successful right now i'm not
saying people won't get it i'm just
saying
the comparison oh you talk about what
they doing okay
comparisons don't make sense
to be honest with you
i i think this is flopping like because
it's just like like if you look at it
from i got you likewise
what have they changed they're charging
you more now like
now now there's three tiers instead of
just playstation now
so it it's just like i think i honestly
feel like that all this is is they want
their foot
in the door in case things go left and
they got to drop all their games in the
service day one so do you
if they if they consolidate and they
consolidate and it's like all right no
three tiers everything is like whatever
one we give you two buying options or
whatever do you think that makes it
better
well i mean ultimate has two buying
options now but the problem with what
that i'm seeing was what place the
whatever the spartacus write a kiss i
don't know
whatever what this is is it shouldn't be
cool it feels like they it feels like
they're taking playstation now the
service and trying to
separate it and charge you more for
other aspects that you had in now what
about right now on playstation now
right now on playstation now you can
play playstation 4 in games and
theoretically you could play five games
when they're put on there like demon
souls right now on playstation now you
can play stream games and it's just one
subscription service and when you read
this it looks like we're gonna separate
those and make you pay more for the
streaming than you want for the ps4 and
five games but we gotta see the pricing
we don't know the pricing we don't know
the first time
that's what i personally feel like
that's why i personally feel like that
third tier
is that tier that they only put in there
and they needed something of value in
there to get to create a third tier
because the stuff goes south because
it's like i said multiple times like
no no it's just where the industry's
going we got plate we got ea access we
got ubisoft uh we got all these
different uh
we got all these different subscription
services clearly
clearly playstation feels like they need
their own version of it and i feel like
right now they don't want to put their
games in there because i don't think it
really dire needs to it because we're so
far uh beginning of the generation but i
do feel like if they start losing some
of that market share because game pass
is a value and people value money over
anything in the entire world i feel like
that they've created that third tier and
put that wax streaming stuff in there
because they needed that third tier
because the stuff going south they're
going to throw get their games in their
day and date in that last chance
well that's that's why i say that that's
why i say
it's an optics things right now because
at the end of the day like we do know
like everybody's on board with saying
that the streaming is the future we're
just not there yet so they need to it's
not even the streaming i don't even
think it's the streaming they're
focusing on like and they're smart for
doing this they're like look
we don't know where this streaming
service and stuff's going people picked
up on it but it does look like it's
gaining a lot of traction we're gonna
put half our body in this door
gonna make our own streaming servers
we're gonna make our own subscription
service but we're not gonna put our
actual games in there because we don't
necessarily feel like it's gonna value
to us right now but if subscription
services blow up in the next two to
three years they've already started the
the walking dead like i have one place
yeah they they're able to just press a
button theoretically obviously it's more
than that they'll have to do stuff in
the back end but then they can just okay
instead of just downloading the ps4
games the next god of war you can get on
their day and day because right now i do
feel like they are low-key scared of
what game pass could potentially be and
they don't want to be in that situation
where they've waited too long to respond
to it
they're doing half measures now in case
stuff does go left and game pass is
starting to really take traction they're
like okay drop the bomb all right so i
got y'all let's get because this was a
page he wanted to get some some comments
in with some of inadequate saying
getting it and then i go out yeah
there's a couple of things a couple of
things one of them the day and date
thing right let's go if xbox game pass
didn't have day and day games if they
came three months six months later
i'd be all over it still i i appreciate
the day and date games and i would have
this difficult decision when a big one
when a forza horizon 5 comes out when a
halo comes out like do i buy it or do i
wait six months in the sony sphere where
those games are single-player story
games every time the answer will be yeah
i'll wait six months so it's only don't
put those games in day and day that is
still a valuable service to me right i'd
still play that and i'll still play all
of sony's games on it i can wait so do
you have a playstation now right now ac
do you have playstation now right now
i'm a weirdo
oh and we got dave
no we're not talking about steady though
do you have playstation now okay
is why i contextualize it i also have
stadium i've never played playstation
now
i got it because i wanted to experiment
with it and i never got around to it oh
so you wanted to experiment make a video
you forgot to cancel your subscription
i experimented and and i i experimented
when i had i said i'm gonna have when i
have gigabit i'm gonna experiment right
continue
i just have one question for asa
what happened to rome how did rome fall
oh my god
and
if you don't know the answer is from
within
[Music]
[Music]
the other one and sovereign and addicts
have both touched on this and i did as
well when i spoke earlier but when they
talk about
battling game pass and positioning this
service against game pass there's two
different persons
so you've got game pass within the
console space and that's the thing like
um microsoft's ambition is way beyond
that but it is a thing within the
console space is the thing that makes
people buy xboxes and that's a battle so
certainly could be and i think this is
probably shorts on what they are doing
so playstation plus has always been
their
way to squeeze a bit of extra money out
of people that already have a
playstation and what they're doing here
to add these tiers and things there's a
battle there to make the playstation
more enticing and to get more money out
of playstation people right and then
there's the bigger battle that game pass
is also running off with to expand
beyond that onto your pcs onto your
streaming onto your phone and everything
and i think like alex says that's
probably
something they're preparing for but not
necessarily engaging with yes at the
first step
okay no no this is great it's great i'll
jump in this is a great discussion oh
shout out to king's messi this and alex
is hilarious too he's but
it's it's not that i don't i feel like
sony just doesn't want to get left back
until i know they they want to make sure
that they have some form of interaction
in case something does happen and they
lose some of the market share no i get
what you say i think you know
for me i'm with solving on the base
level
that this is just consolidation
initially and from a branding standpoint
playstation now let's be honest that
name is not strong out here you know i'm
saying we we know what's going on as far
as like i said they they pioneered the
space as far as the you know cloud in
the console gaming space and stuff like
that and the guy kai deal i remember it
i was i was actually one of the adopters
i would try it i would do remote play i
do all that stuff and it just once
obviously with gay past and all that
stuff came out and you see the azure
background i just felt it was better so
what they seem to have done is position
themselves to say okay kind of like what
attic is saying which is
you know we see where this thing is
going
and you may make the deal with um
microsoft you know they do the the lens
for the what you call it deal keep
laughing
and and position themselves to be okay
in case
they have a better backbone right they
get off the aws
yes kid
i just just one question because i i i
think you just said that they reached
over to microsoft and asked for help
wait a second they partnered with
yourself okay so
they partnered with the people that
could turn the lights
i actually feel like
like acer said that um
he said that he felt like because their
games were single player would still
have value three to six months yeah i i
kind of disagree like i don't think
their games are bad or anything i think
their games are fantastic but since
they're single player there's a lot more
chance that people will the story will
get spoiled or it's not in the news
anymore people are talking about i feel
like because microsoft has more
diversity in terms of multiplayer and
single-player games they can survive
that three to six months that they chose
to i honestly do feel like right now
what we see with jason schreier is i
don't see anything making me feel like
this is anything different than now i
just feel like when i'm looking at it it
just looks like now separated into
multiple different tiers i know what
you're going to look and if now didn't
succeed what makes us think this is
going to succeed like i said i will get
to it when i finish my voice
so like i would say that you know at the
end of the day
i get where you guys are going it's it's
consolidation but the key to me
is that they're even imitating because
let's be real you know they're the
market leader right but they're looking
at what microsoft is doing as far as
game pass they're looking at what
microsoft's doing as far as pc ports
they're looking at microsoft's doing as
far as subscription services so that's
to me there is one eye towards the
future the question for me is going to
be the day and date the question to me
because to me that's the separator
that's what makes game pass what it is
right so if if they
don't do it right and they wait the six
months or whatever whatever you know
maybe that business model is fine for
them at this half measure kind of thing
but i'm curious to see like we see what
was that game destruction all-stars or
whatever
right yeah bug snaps that right they
they we're seeing smaller things so it
may be a situation where it's a baby
step kind of thing you know i mean now
as far as the the movie stuff i kind of
disagree with you i do think that
we will see that they have to make
you're right as as the third tier stands
right now it don't look popping it don't
look to you and to me i agree that
doesn't look enticing
lit
right i just i do i could see you sit
down we've seen reports out the last
game then i'll go check it out my band
monster had one with i've got it's
called playstation video i've got the
actual terminology but it was uncovered
on a polish website that they have some
type of service that's going to be video
or whatever right yeah and and i feel
like that's where fundamentation of
crunch you're right right
right so but but to me
being that they're in this consolidation
phase i could see a scenario where they
can bundle that in to make the third
tier more attractive you know what i'm
saying because you're asking people a
higher thing but you know look at the
end of the day i keep yeah i keep up
with the anime scene the only reason
they brought country ro is because it
was it was competition like they didn't
bot they're they're going to merge the
two apps into one in the future like
they didn't buy it and to me if they
bought it from mainly competition
regions and they'd never
bundle fundamentation in anything gaming
related i don't see why they would all
of a sudden dude they've had fundamental
for a while now right now i get what you
say i just think to your point
they move
they move measured more slower then
let's be honest microsoft is a
trailblazer in a lot of respects they
are very aggressive they were very
aggressive with day and day they're very
aggressive with pc they were even
aggressive with digital like they were
the first to get out there and
eventually the rest of the gaming kind
of caught up and we do it it's not no
big thing but sony's a little bit messy
because look they are the market leader
they are doing well with the traditional
console model right in retail and stuff
like that there's no need necessarily
for them to rush but at the same time to
your point they don't want to get left
behind if it starts to speed ball into
that that situation the only point i'll
say is this where i completely agree
with with solve
as it stands right now it's just not
a competitor in my opinion to game pass
it's just not oh no i think we all agree
on that i don't think no one thinks it
like
i literally said this is gonna flop
i'm not saying it's gonna flop i'm just
saying that
as i just got structured yeah
i got to see something different than
what they've tried like just because you
re-skin it and you say it's a new name
don't mean it's people don't act like
it's
and that's what it is i think it's
largely a reskin that's all it is
i just i i agree and disagree it is a
risky and it is a competitor because
it's a fine margin it's a fine margin of
content to make what they have now or
competitors who came past hey so i think
yes it is a rebrand to tell me how many
playstation now subscription services
are right now what's that number up to
okay
okay you got one
so what's the what's
how many of you guys are out there how
many
two million lost i heard two million two
million
two million two million but playstation
plus is the biggest service two million
the game
and i get that but it's not like they're
merging these together they're going to
have they're actually no you're going to
you've got to pay more you've got to pay
more like it's not like you walking in
there you're probably going to have it
like 9.99 for the opening you walk in
you stretch your feet out for 9.99 then
they're like all right pay me
xbox didn't add xbox live to game pass
and not charge you for it exactly and
they didn't have game date initially
either but game pass was already vibing
when my ultimate was added this isn't
going to happen
good get it i got here the biggest thing
first i gotta hear the biggest things
first
what's the biggest thing what's the
biggest thing back-and-back is behind
the paywall
i don't care what nobody say
what's next you're gonna lock down hdr
too i'm gonna put hdr behind the back of
that wall i mean they already locked
down the controller so yeah
like if you don't pay the ten dollar tax
you can't blow on your controller like
i'm telling you right now this is i
think they want everybody blowing in
that controller what's this this is a
slippery slope man okay i'm sorry
asa burger king down the street is
giving away
free burgers
right and then you can get back to pat
fries
you just walk inside you like man
now i will
i will agree with you guys that they're
more aggressive when they rebrand that's
one thing but is they do exactly what
they're doing now bullhorn and told you
that they got these tears but the thing
is like something like let me ask you a
serious question do you think that when
they call
if they start pursuing the third parties
the resident evils like they start
really
vibing those companies to get their
stuff on that service day but not their
stuff i could see that happening but i
don't see that happening
the first thing like addict you're the
one that's saying that you don't think
those tier listings are accurate you
think that jason's right has got it
wrong so there's no no
no i never said that i said there's
certain things that i don't know that we
know all the information about like as
far as the tears you don't know what the
costing of it is if it's two dollars
more from the second tier to the third
tier maybe they are charging you two
dollars more to place them back that's
bad
so spartacus right is not what this
service is called tier one two and three
is not what these tiers are called so if
they have if it launches and it's
playstation plus as it is now and tier
two over there called playstation plus
statistics game pass
playstation game pass it's tier two
these tiers aren't official names these
are just like how they're internally
discussing it so playstation game passes
tier two and they say
if you get playstation now and we're
adding playstation five games into the
service in what way would that not be a
competitor to xbox game
tier two gameplay if the official name
for that tier is playstation game pass
and it gets you
gains playstation five games right so
that's a game plus competitor
immediately off the bat with a
rebranding right
but that doesn't play doesn't
playstation now already do that isn't
last of us two already on there isn't
god award already on there don't they
recycle these games
so why is it still just
sir
but the margin is so slim between like
at the moment playstation now has
playstation 4 games it doesn't have any
playstation 5 games but it's such a
small step to add them but my point is
all last generation they kept doing that
and it still didn't do anything they
can't keep doing what they're doing now
under a different name and expect
everything to go smooth i just think at
the end of the day if
even if they do what asa says they're
going to do right it won't be day and
date and if the price is even remotely
no no i i understand but speculative yes
yes right correct hypothetically it just
feels like if that pricing is if that
pricing is 15 or more and it doesn't
have those same features
it's a loss on their part like it's just
not again it's going to look
it's going to look negatively upon them
if it doesn't compare in that in that
sense so
i
i i just
i agree completely it's baby steps and
they they well i think it is this baby's
they're sort of taking the temperature
of the water seeing how people respond
to this right because because if they
come out with a with a crazy pricing
scheme
they will the internet will speak you
know this look
this baby steps but this is very bad
baby steps they need this ain't it oh no
no no no no i think it's the i think
it's the right thing to do in that the
consolidation makes sense getting rid of
the ps now name makes sense putting it
over together
i just think they need to get they need
to get to where microsoft is where they
were like you know what even if
piecemeal these things cost considerably
more than what we're charging for as a
group
charging for it as a bundle makes sense
in order to promote it and move it and
grow it right
here's my question to the panel then do
you think if microsoft
2017-18 whatever it was came out and
they never said their games are going
their day and date do you think game
pass would even be as big as it is now
have made this many subscribers be i
don't know i i think it wouldn't be half
maybe 10 million maybe i agree but see
the thing is that what i'm trying to say
is that
we still cannot deny the star power of
their ips and their games we can't deny
the branding that they have that it's
just it is what it is you know say like
they won the generation that microsoft
shouldn't have lost but it wasn't
because of now though right but but they
still are the more recognizable brand
and
i'm
oh
is if they do decide whether it's late
or not
and they decide to say hey
we're going to put first party offerings
in that service oh then it's a wrap
that's what i'm trying to tell people
like no no i i'm referring to what
they're doing now right like i like them
in their mind they may say i don't
believe there's no need for them to do
it initially let's see how we go i don't
believe you yeah
i do not believe what you're saying okay
it takes them five years to produce one
triple a title
okay okay so he's saying they can't keep
up with them
this is where the haymakers come in this
is when the manny pacquiao effect starts
to take flight
microsoft has a ton of studios
this is where we we this is where we get
back together now right i know where
you're going
i'm with you i'm this what i'm saying if
they the quicker they do it in my
opinion is to their benefit to compete
in the long game i'm with you in the
long game that microsoft game pass and
all those third-party game studios when
the dell u starts happening i got you
okay i got you when the w starts
happening
it is going to be harder to compete with
the first party offerings the vow the
hell blade this you know what i'm saying
like back to back to back to back to
back based on the cadence they have not
saying that they're not going to have
any games but i'm just saying that at
some point whether we say 20 22 223
let's just start as that one of the
touch years that a lot of the major
gains will be ready for xbox that will
go day and day we're already seeing on a
small level to me we already see it on a
small level right now at the end of 2021
the potential of how impressive game
pass could be when you have like a
psychonauts age of vampires halo
infinite forza horizon 5 quality
aaa type games inner service basically
coming to free that hit's different we
saw at the top of the year when they had
the third party stuff that hit different
mlb to show the outro i get it all i'm
saying it behooves them if they are
going to do the day and date to get it
going quicker so that they don't fall
behind in the services part that's what
i'll say but again cake i know you went
to okay
it doesn't fit them
day and date does not fit sony
and this is the reason why they don't it
doesn't fit them
their games are too expensive
to promote
right to date so literally they they
have these large budgets for these games
now these games are phenomenal when they
actually do come out yes right
it takes a long period of time it's in
the long production cost you would have
to cut production time and production
money to get these out in a proper
cadence
what's not sustainable for sony
is these limited time exclusive things
that's not sustainable
because if you're purchasing something
for a limited time to keep it away from
a competitor that doesn't care at this
point because their first party titles
will hold them when they start hitting
in that cadence
you'll forget that it's a time exclusive
on that other platform and when it does
become available on your platform you
never thought about it because you never
missed it because you didn't care
because you're too busy over here i get
it
i do i'm afraid with them and this is
the reason why this is the last
playstation console oh god here we go
no i i hear where you're going all i'm
saying this spartacus thing is different
right so this is this is where i told
you this is the beginning of said end
all right
everything they said they wouldn't do
they turned around on a 180 and spit it
right back at you
this is what happens when it's about to
be the beginning of said end
okay that's not the beginning of the end
for the playstation brand right i
actually believe
unshackling them
from that cumbersome console
and releasing them
into the wild on a pc
on a xbox on a nintendo
will allow them to be exactly who they
are
great software developer that's what you
want
the problem is that's not how business
work all the time they're doing well
right now there's no need to rush into
some future when you're caking up right
now on retail my thing is you're trying
to accelerate the future for them
there's no need for them to rush this is
going to take this is okay so
now they're fine they are fantastic
right now with the old model they're
sustainable
with the old model correct i think
everybody on this panel understands
uh
this old model is not sustainable
the same way that we thought physical
like the reason why people take pictures
of this physical stuff that they have
gymnastics collection that they do have
not happy because yeah it's over
right literally you have more digital
games than you had physical
so now that is going to change soon it
won't be any physical you know what's
funny it would be outside of the box on
the playstation it's still mostly
physical
that's the thing look at the uh
the numbers say you look at the uk
physical they never say they buy in
these games
i do feel like some of that digital
versus physical between the consoles is
because of game packages
when people throw that number against
microsoft and they'd be like oh like
this is a negative thing i completely
agree uh because at the end of the day
that base
is more keen to be digital and innocent
they literally which we'll get into the
next topic we'll probably should
transition soon because we won this time
and long is that you know their literal
one of their best consoles is an all
digital console that is literally
winning you know black friday and all
this other stuff so i don't get caught
up with that all day you know they
look how much these guys are dominating
here we we don't have all the data we
don't have what's the digital data
what's going on there until you get a
full scope of the data i don't just look
at physical sales and like okay that's
the indicator of pure success and no
it's that's not how microsoft's running
their their business but all i was gonna
say is i kid i do hear you i know where
you're going
jim himself said he's not happy with the
ceiling right the console space is
limited he wants it to go i don't know
what was the words that he used sir um
what he said damn you are not enough
but anyway
that was the other jim ryan that said
that yes i wanted to get that off but we
should transition because we got we got
a lot of topics you want to get the just
transition right in and then super
chat's right after the next one solve or
yeah yeah that's just true because we
definitely go yeah
it's an interesting but i will say a
funny part i do find funny before we
switch over a lot of people who
say they was gonna support the devs
they don't like subscription services
they i see a lot of that talk king like
this guy i gotta ride with king i see a
lot of people you know there's a lot a
lot of receipts on the internet you know
game pass is bad and you know somebody
would never
do any type of subscription all of you
said be careful when you speak in
absolutes these are companies they're
trying to make money you know what i
mean and at the end of the day don't
care about your feelings they don't care
about how you want to brag on twitter to
other fanpoints they care about making
money so that to me is hilarious because
i'm seeing mad backtracking on twitter
which i think is quite hilarious because
i don't speak in absolutes but that's
what it is get your fandom and
emotionality out of it
the thing that you said would never
happen
is happening right pc
cloud
streaming services
happening
all right so let's just be clear anyways
here we go
gonna head out again you guys might i've
been talking too much my mouth's
starting to hurt again all right brother
i've got you two yes you're right thank
you thank you for pulling up man for
sure um what i wanted to get is all
right so look shout out to give game
spot some bars right now um series s
little man outside kit
a little bit according to the adobe
digital economy index via business
insider no big surprise the series that
has been easier to find in the series x
than the series x but um looks like
they're doing well as far as the black
friday leader the best-selling game
console for black friday and then it
says um combined with the appeal of game
pass according to uh phil spence he said
i think over the generation our
expectation would be that price really
matters and that you will see the series
as sell more and this is uh phil
spenceville dominance maximus are really
expensive comments to kataku you know
what i'm saying so uh let's talk about
it you know this was hitting the waves a
little bit so let's start with ace about
i want to get his feelings on this man
like what what are you thinking about
their the potential reports of the
series s being the best selling console
on black friday
you know i don't actually have masses to
say on this one this is the series s
doing what it was designed to do like
it's the the cheaper mainstream console
being the cheaper mainstream console and
selling to the mainstream
and most most people there's a lot more
people that don't care about resolution
and shadows than the rather do the
series s has got the games catalog it's
got game pass
it's gonna keep doing that yeah that's
good good point man flemish or what was
your thoughts on the black friday series
s affectionately around little man we
call them that so what do you think
about little man winning black friday
it's an awesome win i mean
it is the cheapest of the of the new
consoles right it's the most attractive
um most people are like wow just game
pass with this it's amazing right
because you don't even need to buy a
game too and for three on the backs just
for 300 bucks
then you can jump into the xbox
ecosystem it's a really uh attractive
price point
um
and also it's
readily available yes but the others are
harder to get that is true or
not um
like i do have a small story
when the
series x
was pre-orderable
um i was very lucky
because of gas uh
i reached out to people because i had
the money but not at that particular
point a little bit later
and they they basically uh preemptively
gave the consul to me and saved from
payback later so i said i knew if i
wouldn't get the
yeah i want to do a big shout out for
that um
but besides that i want to say that
if you if i knew was not going to get
the console then
it's going to be a long time before i
can get one
and and
the cvs was still for sale for a long
time here in europe
because it's just so much
more attractive for the main crowd um
but the the real the hardcore gamers who
are always there for the pre-orders and
everything or just always want a high
stop
um
and and that's just one of those things
i think the digital age because of it is
also a little bit more attractive as
well
um
and yeah i just think it's what indeed
what asa said it's designed what it's
supposed to do yeah and i was always
thinking the same thing no doubt no
doubt i see the legend is that the
legendary kid smooth
xbox
is that is that he
looks like he's working all this audio
while that's going on let's get a soft
man what you thinking about lil man
outside what's going on
yeah man just like asa said like it's
doing what it was designed to do and
right now it has the benefit of having
next to no competition right right
so
that that's even magnified even more
where being said yeah when you look at
the the fact that even the hardcore
can't find these the primary consoles
you know the the top of the line
consoles they're going to look to this
and the thing is
one thing one thing
one thing that i i think they haven't
necessarily done well with is
telling people that the console isn't
necessarily that much weaker yeah yeah
it's built more for lower resolution
displays not necessarily at the guts i
agree
um because i had to sort of convince
again the people the people at my job
they come to me asking me these
questions and they're like oh but i
can't find the x but i you know or ps5
but you know the s i don't i don't know
about i'm like listen
what kind of tv do you have and this
continues to laugh at this
no i said i said you have a 1080p tv is
it 4k whatever no they have a 1080p tv
in their room
somebody said tcl which is funny to me
and i'm like the s isn't
when you explain to them that the s
isn't necessarily that much
less powerful just kind of built for a
different type of display and certain
little things are tweaked differently
they were sort of all in on it even with
with the digital thing because somebody
like a parent buying for a kid that's
been in the xbox ecosystem before is
immediately going to be like oh what
about the games the digital games and
i'm like look for right now there's no
way for you if you have those discs
you're not gonna be able to really use
them with this digital system but
if you get into this continue to be in
this ecosystem at some point if you want
to upgrade to the x you will be able to
use the vast majority of those disks so
the the value proposition for them just
future proofing was enough for them to
be like you know what it i'll jump into
this s and i had like five co-workers
that were like yo i can't find any of
these big consoles they try walmart i
shot all this and i'm like if
if you can't find anything and the s is
out there get the s trust me your kids
are gonna be happy and it was just you
know
you could see it right it's funny that
that this news came about and this was
kind of the the what was happening on a
wide scale and to see it more intimately
with people that i know
it just goes to show you that
being out there and sort of being at a
reasonable price
it
really is at that almost sort of like
i'm going to grab this as i walk out of
the store kind of price point right it's
almost impulse buy right 200 is probably
more of that sweet spot um i i it does
not surprise me
but it definitely had some help because
of course
but i but but the fact that it didn't in
i'm not saying it needed that help but
the fact that now it's out there in that
regard
i think this is now this is a rolling
this this is kind of you think the
momentum starts off oh yeah
yeah yeah the the inertia behind this is
going to continue to probably beat a lot
of things okay let me get in the
legendary kid small i see you muted
brother thank you for joining us man
playing at xbox in the buildings what's
going on guys what's up cognito what's
up iron lords how you guys doing what's
up brother chillin chillin what's going
on series asks kiss move what's your
fault little man we call him little man
he outside what's going on little man
man he's pushing weight
yeah outside bitchin
everybody you know all my like um like
non like youtuber like friends they know
like i'm the guy that's like online and
i'm playing games and streaming games my
um one of my friends um
the one that won the infamous xbox one
the madden edition
[Music]
he's had that xbox since wow um
and so he was like yo man i know they
got the tuba i want to get the x when i
get the x i'm like bro i was like the tv
like you i was like hold on like the tv
what are you rocking
yeah i'm like bro i was like okay
you haven't even experienced the xbox
one x
oh good point yeah you don't i was like
at this point the series x is going to
be a game changer yeah so i was like
you're going from he's going for the big
black
the v oh he's going for the vcr
yeah
he had the same one since 20 uh wow
wow
i'm like bro get the series s it's going
to be a game-changer don't worry because
it's like you've never experienced the
xbox one x y you still g i was like you
play all he plays is
uh what's that warzone mm-hmm fortnite
bro oh yeah and i'm like and
occasionally matted oh he's there oh he
lit i was like get the series s you're
going to be you want to be completely
shot and so
he hits me up
the day after no no what happened was
after i read the black friday news i was
like let me check to see what happened
yeah so i was like hey
did you get the series i was like you
won't regret it if you buy it and then
he was like oh yeah i got it i said he's
i had his text message pending for you
and he said the picture of it would just
sit here nice i actually got check up i
gotta check up one of them to see how
he's been doing but i see them online
playing madden and war zone and whatnot
so i know it's gonna be a different
experience but the thing is about the
series that's in my
my argument on why people were coming up
with excuses of why i did what it's
supposed to do
um i'm not buying i'm not buying this
whole thing oh well i got it because the
ps5 wasn't developed
it doesn't make sense um to have to go
for something completely opposite if
you're going for if you let's say if you
have a ps4 and you're waiting on a ps5
for black friday
that's like a dramatic change right at
least if you buy a ps5 right with no
games and you coming off a ps4 you have
not you still have a library right right
he's like all right well maybe i'll play
it better i get the new ui experience
how are you going to jump into an xbox
possibly for the first time it just
doesn't make sense so my thing is you
either was going for a place that you
know you weren't gonna you're you end up
getting something else completely right
i feel like the series s
even like the series that's being
available sure is going to sell i think
any console that was going to be
available yeah would have sold
but
to actually come to the the decision to
buy it there has to be some demand for
it no i'll fill you out for you you know
what i mean you know how many blenders
go on sale on black friday
i don't want a blender so i don't buy a
blender
so the series
i agree with you generally i agree with
you generally smooth i definitely do but
i think when you talk about like a
parent that doesn't know that much about
you know what like if if they're going
in like man this thing that my kid asked
me for it's just not there
yeah
what's something new that's out now and
somebody at the store if they're
knowledgeable they're gonna tell me that
the s is right here and it's a brand new
console so i i get for somebody who's in
the gaming and knows it and you know
what you want and you're not going to
settle for less cool but i think
especially when you talk about black
friday you have parents you have
grandparents whatever going out to buy
to me it's just like it is that thing of
okay what's what's left here because i
saw people i s one of my co-workers that
decided not to go with the s
he actually bought my brother's series
uh 1x he bought his 1x
and he was like nah i need my disc game
so i need a disk drive and he paid he
gave almost 300 for a one wow
wow all right you know saab i actually
all right so it's not that i disagree
with you
i'm just looking at it from i have a uh
lately i've been looking at a one track
i had a one track mine in the second one
you're actually correct because i i
completely forgot or omitted the parent
factor the christmas factor yeah right
right i'm thinking about
gamers who didn't get the series x and
ps5 in time and whatnot right so you are
absolutely right in that case and i can
see scenarios where all right they
they're getting all this
you know mama do sometimes
like what don't play games right they
don't play that war zone he's like
here's that police the police station
fire
knock off jake
you know all right and the thing is you
also got to consider what xbox is this
perfect time even though we really hate
the whole everything being dropped at
that end of the year thing it actually
worked out perfectly for a couple of
reasons
forza horizon 5 the force of horizon's
thing pop most popular for that
franchise at that one particular time
everybody's talking about it yeah
then hail the hype around hillary
clinton
people people associate still even
though it's everywhere people don't
associate halo with xbox correct
i gotta get the x i gotta get the xbox
so it was like everything happened at
once and then they grabbed the meme kid
to do the commercials
like
how to build and you think you fortnight
and then how to offer a race they give
you 14
mm-hmm
that that probably captured a lot of
people all those tick tock kids and all
that stuff like that that did some that
probably helped tremendously and i
i applaud them uh for that because i
feel like their marketing efforts are
helping um this case and then you got
obviously halo being back and it being
talked about it's all over the internet
forza
getting crazy numbers
um yeah i'm like i'm not surprised at
the series that i just didn't i'm gonna
to be with you for the first time cog
i went to
target yesterday i was doing i was
starting my christmas shopping for the
kids and stuff and i was contemplating
[Laughter]
work your way
up they had they had two and they had
two in stock
i'm like oh this is actually cool uh
cool to see i almost pick uh pick one up
for um
kids but then the thing is is that my um
son he was like driving me crazy because
he's been on the sonic binge right oh
and in the bargain bin there were sonic
uh i think sonic forces and then oh for
the back capacitor so you want the disc
for the yeah
yeah let me go grab these on the side
and i was like at that point i was like
i can't really get the series down yeah
yeah cause you need it
i figured those are required of this no
doubt real quick i'll give it the
keyboard oh real quick um
before i switch it make sure your mic is
picking up because you do all come in a
little longer to tell you that so make
sure in the lower left that um zoom is
picking up your correct mic and then
also go into the audio settings and make
sure that the um it's not automatically
suppressing it it's like a check box to
automatically control volume you say i'm
coming in low a little yeah you're
coming in low a little bit but while
you're doing that king go ahead what's
going on with little man man
my man asa hit the nail on the head
let's go
literally it's doing what it was
designed to do
when
that's it
it's designed for utcl lovers
here we go right it is designed for you
tvs at the door dudes
it's designed for you dudes that get
popcorn and tvs at the same time
it's designed for you
all right so
everybody's trying to come up with this
well this is the excuse because the
playstation was individual and you
didn't have 500 anyway
oh my god all right let's stop acting
like he was at the store with the 500
and you was ready to make it happen
because when they said tax she was like
ah
so i know you
you know who else knows you why they got
to be you know
no but you know who else knows you yes
phil
all right so everybody didn't understand
they have this console that's five
hundred dollars when they have this
console that's three hundred dollars and
this console is digital and it's
he was targeting you from the jump
he knew that you the only reason why you
got to play station 4 before because it
was 100 cheaper baby
it had nothing to do with oh i'm a
playstation fan loyalist no a lot of
dudes jumped [ __ ] because it was cheaper
you know something
just make this joint cheaper
i told y'all before and somebody was on
my timeline i remember and i know who
you are
you screenshot this and you said that
you i guess you
actually no you didn't screenshot it you
took a video of me
saying that the series s would outsell
the playstation 5 and as series x
it
[Laughter]
oh it only did it just for this little
bit of time this is just this black it
did it though
[Laughter]
and don't tell me that the playstation 5
wasn't available and the series x wasn't
available so that's why it was outside
though little babe was outside
i don't want to hear what wasn't
available in the store
i got one
why didn't you
i got a playstation 5 why don't you
so don't tell me all this oh you know
this was it only did these numbers
because you're making excuses
little man went out there and got the
pockets of the cheap man
so don't tell me put the little emojis
in the chat y'all
yeah
boys
and she says oh you know what um you got
a series x available yeah we do we got
the other one the series s for 300 300.
that boy ain't been doing good all year
give me the 300 right there
you're back
don't sit there and tell me and
playstation 5 was available there too
they said yo we got some playstation 5.
yeah he really told the little vans of
the chat for you what's that what's that
thing over there that's 300 oh he gonna
get that
[Music]
you you out here uh capping for
playstation five in a series x and you
got a tcl television don't tell me that
your situation is oh you don't have the
equipment to rock with this anyway
so little man is made for you stop
denying it don't run from it don't
escape it it's for you and still knows
it's feminist that's why it's the black
friday champion of 2021
so
i don't care how you how you ring the
bell i don't care how you sit there and
try to justify it you can't run from it
i told you it was gonna happen and this
right here this game pass thing right
here you see it that's for all you
little man loving it you got it i got it
we all got it together
you gotta you gotta rub that in your
chest
you gotta rub it off you gotta rub it in
your chest
and what i told you
at the end of the year when that number
come out for that
told you it's gonna be something nasty
you didn't like me and right now i'm at
97 percent right
boy oh boy
i want i want that person
who took that clip of me mm-hmm oh who
you are and i know who you are too don't
let me go find you
you're sad
little bears in the chat you know why
there's so many little bits in the chat
yo they going crazy right now with the
eyes
little man is rocking your tca right now
and i love it
merry christmas
so when you go to you you got that
present under your tree and you thought
it was a playstation 5 and you go to
unwrapping
this little man
[Music]
[Laughter]
she said oh that's not what you want
well that's what you got
merry christmas
you stupid that was funny i'll give you
that whoo okay
i don't really have that much to add
king said it all it is what it is uh you
know
wow yeah little man is outside very
impressive and uh it'll be cool to see
what happens also with mpd yo they got
so many little bits in the chat because
of your boss it is hilarious right now
but yeah
king said it best it's definitely
you know i i'm not surprised this was
part of the two-prong approach and the
cheaper machine to start point
i've been impressed man i just love how
portable it is i love how i play these
games and i'm not seeing
that huge graphical you know difference
and i'm just like wow this is impressive
playing flight simulator playing
guardians of the guy playing all these
games when i go to the bedroom like yo
and then taking it
portably and then you've seen it do well
also
in markets where traditionally xbox has
not done well at all and i think that is
at least promising for them you know
what i mean so yes we'll see what goes
on let's get a couple of super chat
before we get to the last topic because
i know we got a lot we we got to catch
up merry christmas yeah yeah yeah we
gotta catch up a lot of stuff going on
but actually why are you doing that i
really asked kids to move
i didn't i didn't get his bars on
playstation spartacus because he missed
that and i'm very curious about that
while he's uh waiting for we saw so what
do you think man
uh can you can i can you hear me better
yes
yes okay uh playstation spartacus all i
did like
i'm not i don't really have too much
energy for it it's just more so the the
the big fans of playstation who you know
you know you know the the narrative
against xbox game pass
i want i'm i'm just curious to see how
that's treated is that are the are the
places to see games going to be depleted
or devalued
all that other stuff like you know
rentable service you know you support
the developers you know
all that stuff it's just that's what i
want to see the energy because when that
when that uh jason schreier he broke the
news that's correct
when that tweet broke out aussie this is
good
this is how they should do it some
people got caught in 4k with the tweets
yeah some people got extremely caught in
4k and um i'm i'm happy to see how they
do it because i'm just going i just want
to see if it's going to be cheaper than
gamepad yeah they've got to see the
pricing no no no
got to see the price and um and i think
um it's it's cool but i think um xbox
might have
something well
timed to go into game pass so i'm i'm
not worried about it i'm not like i
tried like obviously but you know we're
all if we haven't played we're on play
position plus
um
for obvious reasons you know you got to
get your cloud saved
um like i've done ps now as an early
adopter of ps now yeah um
i enjoyed the concept um and i'm pretty
sure it's better now but back then it
was it wasn't like um really ideal
um but it looks like you know with all
the talk of unsustainability with
services like that it looks like
something seems sustainable for them to
you know want to try it and i'm just
looking at the moment where people get
these these uh back compact taxes
and are
willing to be uh paying for this as the
as their service that they currently
have is going to get an increase it's
going to lead to an increase and i just
want to see the reaction to that but um
yeah i'm fed up fair enough i see where
you go so we all caught up with the uh
the super chat sir
yeah let me just go to that and make
sure i didn't get anything else
we got to get these bars off for the
people
no doubt yeah i'm good all right let's
get it
all right so we have splendiferous two
dollar super chat nope sorry not
interested in that sony game pass
and we have urban ninja 5 super chat or
you can pay twenty dollars and play ps1
and ps2 games on an xbox
yes we know we know about that
the little man sure there we go
hard geek city two dollar super chat
multiple tiers to create pony tears oh
my god wow
then we have geek geek head 188 five
dollars a bit
sony really making a bootleg game pass
for the dog water console
and we got the homie italian clowns
remember for 11 months shout out to
clowns
what's up shout out to all the cool
peeps here on camera right now thank you
sir no doubt
then we got
drawn tj five dollar super chat morning
lords good afternoon sir good afternoon
then we have heart chinese five dollars
from chat
we always give sony a lot of leeway when
it comes to what we want versus what we
think they'll do we should just demand
that they put their games in day and day
yeah we can demand all we want
there we are once again you cannot
defeat my state in style five dollars
sony hey can i copy your homework xbox
yeah just change it enough not to notice
sony don't worry fam we'll make the tcl
first wow
savage
then we have italian clowns five dollars
super chat game pass one dollar and
holla
give it a try sony can't afford to put
games day and date they can't even
discount ghosts with sushi but they need
some money wow really clowns get your
flavish get your bed
get your host
he's running loose
then we got lonzo 86 five dollar super
chat solve sony has to go with streaming
or else they have to hunt down licenses
for ps1 ps2 ps3 games like xbox did ps5
can emulate ps3 cell processor salute
should be able to also i don't think the
streaming absolves you from having to
get licenses if i if you recall i think
before geforce now went live officially
some games that they had in beta in the
service they automatically
move them over without updating the sort
of
agreement they had with the with the
developers and the publishers and there
was a problem so i don't think
cloud has anything to do with it they
just need to get the license for the
game
um
salute to the realm in the chat much
love everybody no doubt my brother
then we got hargett cheney once again
five dollars to be chat designed to make
more money for sony consumer unfriendly
ponies will defend it playstation is
definitely for the payers
where pay where pay happens
wow really okay
okay y'all outside
then we have render two dollar super
chat every tier of spartacus is a tear
of joy for king
there's gonna be four tears
then we have flame five dollar super
chat good afternoon fellas i'm sad
spartacus will devalue games and devs
will stop being paid oh well
back to watching the halo reddit war
later
for being that was actually good though
then we have rob the don 202 five dollar
super chat let's not sleep on the pc
angle let's not forget there's a room
where the playstation is building their
own storefront on pc which they could
put this in i got one i think we missed
between lonzo 86. find out something you
got that one
yeah solve sony has to go yeah oh my bad
my bad
i got him
um
super chat worldwide jim needs to come
tell us what's up
you don't know you don't know
michael aka best size finest two dollar
super chat i just wanted to show love to
the lords god bless
then we have jay nichols two dollars
super chat xbox buying square sony doing
a sega move
then we have the liz22 five dollar super
chat majority of gamers are not hardcore
ultra graphics they play free to play
madden 2k cod and or game pass series s
is an unbelievable piece of tech yes it
is
then we got the king of flip flop
5 super
my brother my brother salute the
chocolate that king yes salute lords
king not like this said the answers for
doorbuster tvs on black friday lol only
you know but it is kind of true like if
you're online busting through a walmart
door at whatever hour friday black
friday
[Music]
you're getting
it's not even tcl man you're getting
something else you're getting
yeah he didn't get it like he didn't get
it on like yeah
yeah
exactly he didn't fight with a karen to
get his uh hit him with that he got that
hashtag no and she's fought as i see you
rap i see what you're doing
then we got the list 22 once again
remember for 10 months
xbox series s plus one year of game pass
ultimate is 480 which is greater than
ps5 disc plus one year ps plus plus one
new first party game six hundred and
thirty dollars
then we got kitsmo remember for one year
thank you sir i think he upgraded to
bronze or whatever i just it just popped
up did you get slow and face 23 i got it
no i missed it but then i got it okay
okay
uh then we got philly eagle member for
two years lord gold the series s ilp
mom what is what the perfect console for
bedroom tv and my kids series x i'll
people get back on the monster in the
living room what's good lords loving the
episode that's true that's the homie
give him hit him with a book of x he hit
him one of those no doubt then we got
slow-mo back slap two dollar super chat
i got two little mans paws
you out there
are the two little mans in the bedroom
[Laughter]
13 million ps5s confirmed sold and
around 8 million estimated series
council sold so i do do i think everyone
jumping ship like you say you don't
think everyone jump in [ __ ] okay um so
let me answer your question
um you saw microsoft filling their
server blades up so you can have some uh
form of good uh
azure service right what's in those
servers
uh sir
series x's right why are they not
outside in production if they wanted to
flood the market with them you see what
they did with little man
right
did you really want that to happen to
your playstation 5 to really get buried
under the the tundra
so what they did was they put little man
out in the street and they said yo we're
gonna take at least six million out of
circulation we're gonna throw them in
the server blades so this playstation
can breathe does that evolve that's how
they do it then we're gonna let you
breathe a little bit cause we're gonna
make it hard for you to breathe in a
second so right now
it's gonna be hard for you to breathe in
a second right now you you eating dry
biscuits for christmas like literally
there's no games hey yo
anyway yes oh this guy i love your super
chat by the way thank you salute the
face of the face
five dollar super chat psa traded in one
a one s for 215 and two one x's for 3.25
each at gamestop series s is available
for 300 yeah you people are eating the
game right now for sure yeah
uh let's put the crust in the chat for
the newest member of the round relish gt
oh
yes you sir
all right then we got lord roughness my
power super
day one series s right here no regrets
and loving life 200 pounds saving and
game pass gives me plenty of cash for no
ashes
shout out to you in the monetization
model for halo infinity you got extra
money to spend sir
and we have gamingnomics the 100 rupee
super chat
this fanboy stuff must be something
limited to the west i think because in
india every playstation fan i know said
they need something like game pass yeah
it's just it's it's the it's the small
minority you know that's that's how it
happens what else we got alex and we got
alex escortesa five dollar super chat
can't wait till sony makes you pay ten
dollars extra to unlock 4k controller
features on the sony game pass
wow that was loose
and i believe then we have army no we
got a couple of suicides suicide king
suicide kings five dollar super chat
somebody tell king that my mother loves
her tcr series six but then again she
does wear glasses
that was crazy so we all cut up there
right and then let's put the crest in
the chat for the latest member of the
realm army veteran
big shout out to you thank you thank you
so let's get this last one and we will
roll after this battlefield y'all this
is me um
yeah vince man vince impeller put a big
revamp to put him in charge so um looks
like the franchise will now shout the
games industry diabetes the franchise
will now fall under the responsibilities
of lord vince sampela who ready heads up
ea's respawn entertainment and dice los
angeles studios it says it's unclear
what the extent of his involvement will
be with the franchise but he's been
appointed and then laura c.o.o laura
miley i think she says
he creates a culture defining
entertainment that resonates beyond
games we're bringing in one of the most
influential and talented individuals in
entertainment to a franchise that is
ready to be unleashed into the modern
era of gaming it's an extraordinary
inflection point in gaming history so
basically she's you know raving about it
and the acquisition events to kind of
lead this shared down universe of
battlefield games and
gotta talk about it gotta talk about it
this is rise to power and what you guys
think so let's start off with lord
asa what are you thinking about vincent
pella heading the battlefield franchise
i don't like it i don't like it i like
it so vince is those things that that
they say he's done phenomenal work at
infinity ward and then at respawn
and
call of duty when when they were making
that and titanfall were fantastic games
really tight tight tight gunplay
multiplayer oh yeah yeah he's good he's
good at what he does all right
battlefield has always been something
very different to call of duty and
titanfall yes
battlefield i don't like battlefield
but i respect and i admire battlefield
and i see it for what it is and it's
it's an amazing property and the stuff
that they do with it and the spectacle
for me when i play battlefield i run
across the desert for ten minutes and i
get run over by tank or i run across the
desert for ten minutes when i get sniped
in the back of the head with someone
that's been lying in the bushes for that
whole ten minutes
and they they had this hashtag like
battlefield moments where they're
jumping out of helicopters and shooting
rocket launchers and
landing on a camper van and blowing that
up with c4 i don't know all of these
things that's not a battlefield moment
the battlefield moment is the moment at
the end of your 10-minute run where
something kills you and then you start
again
saying that i look at it and i respect
it for what it is and i appreciate that
a lot of people enjoy it right that can
get the hang of it better than i can
so yeah and it's got this spectacle and
i don't necessarily want it to be
refined to a formula that we know works
i don't want it to be refined into the
call of duty formula has done so well
for so many years i want them to keep
what battlefield has always been and
build on that spectacle and grandeur
so i mean hopefully he's the man to do
that but
he's got pedigree and doing the other
kind of first-person shooter so we'll
see
at least you're open-minded about it i
respect that lord flemish are you a
battlefield guy does this news excite
you
well let's first of all say i've not
really been a battlefield guy ever and
this new one is fun but i play it
against bots
single player
that's how i play this battlefield
because if i play a multiplayer i'm dead
9 to 10 times i can maybe kill one guy
and i'm dead so if i play against
the bots i can still win some you know
shout out to the pods shout out to the
bots right now i respect that
if if i'm thinking about titanfall and
isabella and what he brought to the
table with all those games is amazing
right um i don't like battle royale so i
don't think about apex but you do know
it's a very successful game how it plays
how snappy it is
um
let's bring it a little bit together i
would i would see something which
what that just imagine this right
battlefield with max
okay okay okay so you what you want him
to put the titanfall influence
it wouldn't be battlefield well not
really not really but just imagine just
having a little bit more in the future
okay
okay
the guns that play a little bit not the
same like of course you cannot you can
you're not going to copy it one for one
right
but just bringing what he
brought the vision with titanfall just a
little bit more into battlefield would
make it extremely
exciting for me okay um
now i i
the the cool thing about the new
battlefield is it's all like contained
in one thing why not just add new things
to it after one yeah and and just new um
new future um
just make it bigger and bigger like
we're going to see probably with haley
he's going to like it bigger and better
he don't want to run across that map for
two hours that's ace i don't like that
i would think bigger and bigger
new modes new time zones i see it just
growing i mean we got the portal mode
you can play everything in there it's
awesome i won't see the expand on it i
think vincent paul can bring some
interesting ideas that he did with those
games
also in this
uh
franchise
but we'll see what the future holds for
him on the dynamic side respectful i
respect it open-minded little kid smoove
i'm very curious battlefield vince how
you feeling about this and i forgot
kevin you're a battlefield god forgot no
absolutely
yo it's not that bad i feel slammed in
here
i'm
like it's just not my like i'm
dude i'm like
i yeah i have no business talking about
i'm bad i'm just yeah there's no words
like i'm bad at it so it's literally a
franchise i just don't do not invest in
um but the thing about vince zampella
he's literally been the knight in
shining armor for ea
like that blanket that there's anything
negative that they do because of
his work and you know his lead and what
they've been able to do whether it be
titanfall whether it be that i fall in
love
um
whatever wherever he's at they know um
that the franchise is going to be in
good hands yes sir um so shout out to
vince and this is a
a a nice little move for him let's see
what he does uh but he's really been the
savior of ea factual factual i'm with
you on that lord solve where we at big
battlefield guy right
i mean i i played a lot of bad company
one and two battlefield 1942 back in the
day um and i played a lot of four when
the when the you know 2013 when the
consoles launched um the xbox one so i
did but um yeah i kind of fallen off of
it um
i just think they still have to figure
out when it comes to battlefield how to
create
small engagements for people where they
feel like they can be successful and not
spawn into a place where they're gonna
get sniped by a dude two miles away like
that kind of stuff they still have to
figure out um
i don't
like this simply for the fact that it
just feels like
not the fact that vince has taken it
over but the fact that it is once again
they get they're like they refused
to not go for this hanging fruit which
is we have to turn it into a living game
we have to turn it into this
i think they just it just doesn't make
any sense
you can release great battlefield games
and have a different sort of
overarching sort of
uh kind of
sense of what you want to do with with
the uh with the franchise and it not
having to be this this thing that prints
money all the time because it's hard to
to sustain that now do i think vince's
if they want that which is what it seems
like they want is vince the guy to sort
of
fix that
be able to sort of address the issues
that people have with battlefield create
a living game that is successful and at
the same time maybe bring back the
narrative stuff that some people are
probably missing because what i do think
that makes fortnite successful
um is the fact that
it isn't
doesn't necessarily not have any sort of
narrative in it right there is some sort
of underlying meta that sort of ties
everything together that i think is
important for games like that right and
i think just throwing battlefield out
there this time with nothing behind it
just multiplayer and the multiplayer not
being you know as tight as people
expected it to be um
it it hurt it so to me if you want to
create this universe now where
everything sort of feeds into one thing
i think vince is the guy to be able to
do that do i agree that that's where it
should go no not necessarily but i think
to make it successful vince is the guy i
mean this is the guy that brought you
apex is the guy that turned that turned
call of duty into essentially an esport
with cod four so um
yeah so i think and when it comes to
narrative these guys have been doing it
forever too so i think they can
incorporate that as well so vince is the
ideal guy for this i just don't know
that this is what anybody wants
little kids battlefield guy let's go
yeah well you know i am i've played
every battlefield that came out um i
actually like this battlefield to be
honest with you um and i had a couple of
those moments that they show in eclipse
where you're actually doing all this
death defying stuff like jumping on a
tank and throwing a grenade inside and
the dude hopping out and i'm popping him
in his brain i'm just calling down my
dog while we were running down on some
other dudes and i had ran out of bullets
and i'm hiding behind the truck and i
knife to do so
right so i'm having fun doing those
things but uh vince okay so let's get to
it uh for you guys that don't understand
vince is your consolation prize
that game was set up to fail
in a year
where call of duty is probably at its
worst
right um and you have halo in its
infancy in in the beginnings with the uh
progression problems you know
even though halo it's going to do what
halo's going to do they didn't launch
with uh the single player so you're just
launching with a multiplayer
you had the golden opportunity to launch
that game inside game pass
you had the golden opportunity
to get 30 plus million eyes on your
title
and you
passed that opportunity up
you decided to put it out there like
this is uh some bouncing baby that
everybody loves that everybody flocks to
when they're going to buy and this is
fantastic when you have always been
third rung
so you've actually felt fallen behind
war zone
a free-to-play game
you understand and and apex which is uh
vince's
a little darling yeah you do you
honestly think he's going to create
something that can uh eclipse his
darling
what is what are you thinking oh so you
think it's a mistake for them to get
faced i think it's a huge mistake
because the first of all you're
compounding the mistake
with another mistake
that's not his franchise that's not
something that he cares about so he's
not going to have loving caring hands
with it because he didn't right so
first of all you made a mistake when you
took away the story portion from the
game
mistake number one
this is what people went to to play
separated make two separate uh uh game
modes or whatever
the losses to call of duty
has hampered your judgment
and in a moment where you could have
snatched victory from the jaws of defeat
you didn't take it
now
halo is free to play
and and like asa pointed out earlier
halo seems like it's tied to xbox even
though it's free to play every place
else right
so the the idea of it being locked to
the game pass uh ecosystem is very
powerful
it's in there
you could have had halo dudes that was
disgruntled with the progression
system jumping to your game
yeah you could have the people the the
the eight to ten million people that
were playing forza horizon
put eyes on your game
the game so you saying the game pass was
a mistake they should have taken
advantage that's
something
i only played it because it wasn't game
pass and it was the demo remember that
i didn't purchase
i would have
but i sitting there i got so much to
play i can catch it later i figured
i said this is the problem
when
you you you make these
thoughts in a vacuum
you see this guy who had success with a
title that you didn't think would be
successful
and it was successful because his past
franchises that he did put out was
successful in a vacuum they weren't
commercially successful right
now his commercial success
clouds your judgment
you've made blunder after blunder i
don't think think vince is the man for
this job
all right but again i could be wrong
time will tell yeah because he is uh a
savant in in the things that he do uh
well so hopefully
like asus said he doesn't take the
formula of battlefield and turn it into
titanfall battlefield uh you know
hopefully he doesn't want that
and and and
dude
yeah but what i'm hearing it's supposed
to be a hero shooter
you know and
you're going to lose battlefield's
uniqueness the thing that they had in
their main competitor which was call of
duty
you're going to lose that something and
when you lose that something you become
just like everything else
and that's what gets me about this move
is that you've seen it already you've
seen when you when you get to the party
late
hello anthem
so i'm like why would you want to do
this to instead of just fixing what
battlefield is and addressing the things
that the players have issues with and
giving about a statement recently right
they did but so but the statement okay
they're going to fix 2042 right
but at the end of the day this is
probably the last battlefield they get
that's like this you're probably going
to get this living thing after that
right
why i disagree with king that i think
they picked him because they want him
they want his expertise in making apex
and i get it like it's not his baby
they're paying him very well he's going
to make it great right but i don't think
it's going to be battlefield anymore
or or he can go crazy and make it
bigger than it's ever been
um and and because the thing is
on console now how many players do you
have uh now 128 at a time something like
that yeah something crazy 64.
right and then the problem is like
people that you load into the game
sometimes and you're in the middle of
this skirmish and you have no idea what
you're doing you have no idea what to do
and what he loves though
he want to walk across the whole
he want to walk across the continent he
loves it
and i thought they did a lot of stuff to
sort of uh remedy that with the with the
with the jet pack stuff or the freaking
uh whatever the the
the gliders or whatever and the and the
the grappling hook kind of gets you
moving across the board a little bit
faster
it's just to me a lot of it no it's
because i i the thing is i would rather
vince just vince is working on a lot of
stuff right obviously
respawn still doing their stuff or
whatever
but
it just feels like you why would you try
to go down this well again it's like
they refuse to let it go like no we're
going to make this money
[Music]
come hella hot make it hot though so
what if they try to save it but they
failed multiple times already they
already they had they had battlefront in
the in the loot box fiasco they couldn't
get your money that way nobody wanted
that
then they had anthony they tried to turn
and instead of making anthem a fantastic
15 hours i was born i was bus solved
that was bioware fiddling around we got
we got jason schreib with the snitch
reports in the in the room and they
waiting for buffs not doing nothing
it's the umbrella it's not a herb
spots no and i also heard that it was
respawn's choice to release titanfall 2
at the same time that that um
that battlefield whatever came out and
then titanfall 2 got eaten alive
so
i get it i get hey you want to spread
your wings you want to be different i
get it
but just it just feels to me like
you keep going down as well in the chat
as i'm in the chat said like they're
here to stay those get free to play here
to stay right
i get it
just fix the core of it right address
the core of it and then put everything
else around it like you see with halo
halo if you remove all the free to play
stuff it's still core halo right and a
payload fan is going to have fun with
that right my worries that they changed
this and they turned it into something
that's not battlefield okay and it's
just
another attempt to sort of grease money
right to do the call now let me jump
because clearly i'm going to be the only
one on the battlefield side so i would
have to defend against all of you
savages
but uh look i mean you're look in all
seriousness you guys making fantastic
plays it's not nothing you guys are
saying it's really crazy
out of pocket i get the sentiment you
know for me
it's a big deal though i think you know
especially since respawn was acquired to
see vince's ascension in that building
it's pretty remarkable to me because
let's be honest ea
historically don't listen they do what
they want to do they're going to chase
the bag right
so to me
he comes in there first of all let's
just put respect on his name every game
in my opinion humbly every game he's
made has been fired i don't think he's
made a whack game yet that's just me
personally even with i'm not even
neighbor fix your face kiss move i see
you
i see you laughing let me have this kid
let me come over man we go we got to go
through titanfall
title 4-2
jedi falling order a pet like bro he
outside i mean the greatest call of
duties are his call of duty's modern
warfare you know what i'm saying like
that man
to me this is what i knew he was that
dude
because we all heard the reports of
anthem
you know obviously wasabi state is
correct it's a joy effort bioware master
ea force and frostbite i'm saying
when they sound respawn
off rip
zam peller was like we used an unreal
fam
even though the mandate in the building
was for ea would love you to use
frostbrite their proprietary
engine they would not like you he had so
much cachet i don't know we're over here
we're doing this
and that to me and then the other thing
is let's be real like solve i know
solving single player exclusive i mean
get gamer
for them to put out a game like jedi
fallen order really doesn't fit the
traditional ea model with the michael
tran and for him to show look you let me
do it
look what's going to happen right so all
i'm saying is i agree with y'all you
know battlefield network let's just call
it what it is i agree with king
harley it looks like it wasn't a big
mistake that they didn't take advantage
of the game pass thing now that we look
at it in hindsight you know but the
issue let's let's just put it where's
that 70 percent
population drop
that is atrocious on steam
you drop 70
of your player base yikes right so to me
somebody said halo out
[Laughter]
to me i'm cool with the lifeline the sos
get vince in the building
get
where's [ __ ] at somebody hit the bat
phone where is he at throw him back
whatever we gotta do now this is where i
agree with saul
ken king and asa
i do i am nervous on one that flicks i'm
sam's my guy i love me some fish the
only part of nervous is when i hear
terms of we're going to make an
interconnected universe of all these
developers making battlefield games and
he this developer can make better i
don't know how i feel about that part
because that sounds like
the call of duty cycle
which is an annualized franchise which
is sledgehammer makes it this year this
one makes it that year right you know
like i don't know if i want like this i
do kind of like that you miss
battlefield a little bit and then they
have more of a bigger development cycle
if this means annualization
i don't know how i feel about that
so
i have to see i have to see more but um
yeah and the last thing i will say on an
unrelated note i just want to get us off
is that um it is a shout out to respawn
but it is sad what happened to titanfall
though i don't know if you heard about
the um the hacking and now they're
taking it he can't buy it no more and
these hackers have kind of got in there
and and really run ram [ __ ] ramp it it's
really bad but um look i love that's why
they took it off the yeah well what it
is they got almost to the source code
these are like like maniacal fans that
got a hold of it they got it's so bad
i've never seen this
where they were like you have to
uninstall the game
from your thing because it's such a
security breach
that it wasn't safe for you to have the
game on console i thought it was just a
pc thing they were saying they were like
no no so they've taken over and i guess
respawns back to the counter is like yo
we're just not gonna sell it anymore the
servers will still be live but they're
not gonna sell anywhere and it's pretty
sad because but i guess their intention
was like you guys wanna you need to fix
this and then we want the titanfall
online thing and then they try to debo
it and then strong arm and try to you
know use the source code again it's a
bad ugly situation but i just wanted to
shout that out but look we'll see what
happens but i do understand the concern
that's all i got let's give you some
chats and uh you know out of here
yes well while you do that i will do the
poll and then um get some outros while
you're waiting okay all right cool um
final iop paul
with the recent rumors of the
playstation spartacus subscription
service what do you need
to see happen to make it a true rival of
xbox game pass the choices are a
nothing
additional needs to be added sony is the
market leader and consolidation of ps
plus mps now is more than enough b
playstation first party games dtv in the
service day and date or it will not be
able to compete with game pass well c i
don't care i'm supporting all the dabs
by not buying my any subscription
services unless it's on the platform of
my choice
please hit it when it goes up in the
realm first of all let's salute the
legendary lord asa rocking with us from
james or
[Applause]
listen man a tremendous gaming history
super knowledgeable love what you guys
are doing in the space huge fan man and
uh gaming history is great telephone
people what you got going on and where
can they find you man i i've appreciated
all of that i've loved my time on this
show and i love watching it every week
so i'll be back next week in the in the
chat love seeing what's going on um
you can find me on the game on daily
youtube channel the game on daily
website so we've got our go live show
every saturday um
and i've got my own little channel so
i'm on twitch pretty much every day
playing all sorts of things and i've got
a youtube channel where i just upload
bits and pieces those are both acer
underscore game on daily
and you find me on the xbox and the
playstation and the vr and everything
that's not nintendo
salute
brother you had us dying man it was
absolutely hilarious i loved it man
great great stuff and uh yeah i wanna
get also shout out my main lord flemish
the positive gamer making his ilp debut
for guys with quarters retro renegades i
believe as well where can i find people
find you what you got going on sir
yeah uh so first of all you can find me
on 4gq tv of course where we're doing a
lot of stuff uh we're going to have a
huge huge amount of giveaways at the end
of the year
uh we'll be giving away controllers
gamepads and all kinds of other stuff
nice um
but besides that you can find me on the
flemish experience
uh which is gonna be live
um just after the show but it's every
sunday evening at 8 00 p.m um
7 p.m uk where they are what's the
channel what's the channel name sir i
don't know what the channel name where
where could i find it blemish okay
make sure you get your balls off baby we
gotta get your balls
[Laughter]
besides that i do have to give a shout
out from clowns of course yes um he is
doing something special
as we all know a couple months uh a long
time ago uh some time ago uh dizzy lord
dizzy um
had a unfortunate uh passing away and
his son
parker um who's dear to clowns um
said that he was doing a toys for parker
yes um
funding um
like a fundraiser initiative yeah yeah
and he first of all wants to say thank
you for the ironlords of course for um
like contributing to that and if if you
want to also help uh parker get some
more toys uh for christmas basically um
he he wants to
everybody to help him if they can
absolutely i appreciate it for sure yeah
man we want to shout out shout out to
italian clowns we've been talking and uh
because at the end of the day dizzy's
family obviously we lost dizzy earlier
this year and uh shout out to to rosie's
wife and parker your beautiful son and
to see uh shout out to clowns for
getting behind that and saying he knows
what it is to to lose a father and you
know at the end of the day we want to at
least provide some comfort so shout out
to clowns for spearheading that
initiative we see the toys we've seen
this stuff i showed it all dizzy's wife
rose the stuff she's very thankful and
hopefully parker will have a a a better
christmas you know so salute to you and
thank you flamish for bringing it up it
really meant a lot to us that you guys
the realm got behind them so salute four
guys salute italian clowns the homie
rest i see you clowns rest in power and
if clowns if you got any link or
anything that you want to put in the
chat please do to let people know about
it or whatever you want to do because
obviously we trust you that i know you
would solve working behind the scenes on
that one so salute that is what's up but
yeah man of course we have the best spot
making his return it's been a minute
feel like i've talked to you in a minute
brother good to see you i see you moving
to shake it i was trying to uh saw you
on colts xnc that was fun had the super
chat you the homie what's going on man
where can the five people find you
uh you can find me on uh youtube
kidsmove that's the channel i've been
trying to drop a video every other day
playing halo man i can't get off so
every time i
uh i play i i want to stream it uh but
that's what i recently did just broke my
custom
labs controller punch oh
stick out of it but i did it
and i'm embarrassed but um
also follow me on twitter uh shout out
to ilp you guys like i said always
killing it love to uh you know tune in
and and be a viewer every sunday
um and yeah man i hopefully i i'm i'm
able to experience the game awards with
you guys yes oh pull up pull up yeah
yeah for sure pull up bro pull up oh
that's an invitation you already know
that's vip tobacco anytime you want to
pull through on uh on streaming and the
award stuff we definitely like all that
man so salute
no doubt no doubt you already know elm
lord sob you want to get the joint or
actually you want to do actually let me
get king that's good give his outros to
asa and kid and you know flemish
okay well uh i'll start with asa
my fellow uh well
i'm at 97 he's at 98.
prediction
i think swami club swalley club
prediction club this is this is the
highly intelligent uh
where we are cursed with seeing
we're cursed with the knowledge
of being right all the time such
humility such a burden that you do have
this is so ridiculous
we can't be stopped
he said eyes on a roll oh it's
absolutely crazy but i like like i said
i love i actually when i go on game one
daily it is my mission
to mess with acetate
is my mission and it's so much fun
because he is such a good sport and it's
uh it's it's a really fantastic time i
love seeing you here so uh my wife i
popped in she was like who's that guy
right i said uh that guy is the guy show
who i was on before that's asa
she's like oh
yeah i kind of remember that background
that's nice
so she remembered
thank you for coming through brother i
do appreciate the time um flemish me and
you has been a party together before uh
yeah yeah okay so we can't talk about
that
he shut him down real quick he's like
whatever happened
let me say one thing you know me as a
positive gamer right
until i play games
yes
yo um
truly a fun dude um we need to have you
on from the beginning to get your
history and stuff like that i mean
seriously a true fun dude i jumped in a
party with him in clowns and uh like he
really hangs out with clowns and talks
to clowns and he's a real genuine and
they play them games yes yeah yeah for
real he's not he's no joke um so
blessings brother thank you for coming
through kids move you already know what
it is
uh yeah i lost my knees to this guy
oh it was an nba live joke
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
psyche
that's your consolation bro
it was the head fake right
but thank you for coming through brother
appreciate it uh everybody i want to try
to go to the lords of gaming.net uh
there's a whole bunch of stuff up there
right now yes sir and like a congress
thing
it's uh it's a very special uh write-up
that's up there right now so please go
check that out um
i have a cold
there's covered stuff and it's winter
time is killing me
so
but i am warm at night knowing that
little man won black friday you know
what i comforted you
i gave you the heat through the tough
ties
shout out to a little bit let me give
y'all a quick thing this week we didn't
i saw i was like what's that topic yeah
yeah man so i came up with the little
man drawing i was like you know little
man black friday but the gift that keeps
on giving bad news is always brought to
you on a friday
bro shout out to mine i said a new cycle
of rice it was late as hell
thank you thank you spartacus
because you have made this show today
and i'm pretty sure
knowing more stuff to come you will make
future shows just as great
thank you for imploding from within i'm
watching rome burns
oh my god
ridiculous
he definitely got his bars off salute to
him one day so look we got to get this
are you queued up so
yeah i'm pretty high school so look i
want to be fair to everybody around
because we keep people hostage we got to
really super chat if people got to go it
is all good because we got to pay the
realm for it
let me get my outro about these guys i
forgot why we get left out
first off to our brother kids move i
love seeing you all coat man you were
cool
it was so funny um yeah so i i just love
seeing you grow man and you know maybe
work with the anger issues you know when
you throw stuff around
i love you
um
flamish uh you guys over there for grabs
recorders i love you guys uh the
positive game of flamers i remember the
first time i saw that i was like oh
that's interesting what kind of takes
does he have
and i remember just listening to four
guys i'm like i love what you guys are
doing over there
and asa i remember the first time we
went on game on daily
and i'm like i see ace and asa had the
fireplace behind him yeah yeah
and i'm like
oh i know what he's about he's about
laying back
and waiting to just dispel the smoke you
know what i'm saying like any time gas
comes up with something i think it was
me and you on their cog i don't know if
we all all three of us were on there at
that point
and it was just like i felt bad because
i thought we were like not letting asa
speak enough
but then i realized the ace of what he
does he comes in and he just shoots you
down like you're wrong
[Laughter]
yeah i love i love like the dry
sarcastic dry wit and of course sega
saturn love all your brothers brothers
to the end so thank you for coming
through there
yeah oh that saga that's not yeah yeah
that's an official bro if they ever ever
bring that game back
so yeah that's that so i'm gonna read
these super chats so look before we
watch it because this is gonna be a
while
okay flamish
kid if you guys need to go it's all good
we got a ton of super chat then we're
gonna end this no we do actually not a
ton
because usually
we know how we do okay no no because we
caught up before so okay actually it's
like four or fives but i'm stupid
if you guys have to absolutely
so we have our army veteran five dollars
we chat what's up all finally can catch
some live show king is the prophet of
xbox and con that blood on the sand is
dope
we got that 50 you got that bullet you
better probably pay like a hundred
dollars on ebay though salute
upwards of two now wait 200 now yeah
yeah
yeah i'm good i caught
there we go mexican zoidberg remember
for 12 months shout out sir i would like
to thank king for the un unabashed tcl
shaming i picked up at lgc one and i'm
in gaming heaven right now for my tcl
brethren upgrade
[Laughter]
then we have mr irishman member for five
months lord silver plagiarism
plagiarism station is at it again first
it was xbox live then achievements party
chat and now game pass spartac spartacus
gives off expansion pack energy
wow
messy
i see um so this next one from flame i'm
not hold on there we go yeah okay flame
five dollars for chat did anyone catch
something that was said about that press
release putting the player at the center
are we sure that's vince where's phil at
uh spartan ghost the next two uh i'm not
gonna read out brother like i said we
will address this stuff
when it's actually in the in official
channels right
but thank you appreciate it we have a
total of four pound super chat so thank
you so much we appreciate it
we got the homie one away dragons five
dollars
halo drop iop my brothers we either
gonna get some smoke on these streets so
we're gonna give out the smoke halo is
life let's go shout out to the flemish
salute to 108 man pulling up i see
you've seen them halo clips
yeah there we have uh italian clowns 10
super chat we have
toys for parker everyone can contribute
share talk about it let's make it an
awesome uh christmas for parker dm me if
you want to find out more also cog saab
iop can forward you the uh the
information and we can get in touch so
yes definitely uh we're looking to have
parker have an amazing christmas so uh
thank you to everybody who sort of
donated already and uh yeah please uh do
your part if you can um
let me read can i read this email now
all right before you do the email let me
just get the job let me get the merch oh
yeah just gotta get the brunch um shout
out to gamer by choice he said he got
the uh again the classic t he said i
just wanted to support the realm so
salute to him he got the classic t and
he got the flask salute to him shout out
to philly eagle he got the classic t he
got the um the unity joint all the cars
were different colors he said what's
good iop salute and he got the backpack
salute to him and then anonymous got the
shout out for to put your name he got
the new king got the new aurelius phil
dominance oh that's a really expensive
shirt
with the chalice in hand
put your name so we can shout you in the
chat okay solve i'll let you out with
this uh what's this all right so like i
said at the beginning of the show i'm
going to waste your time a little bit
this was funny to me because i was
having a horrible day and and and this
made me laugh to no end this is spam
mail that we got into lognet
and so i just usually just delete it but
this one i happen to look at
no
it says hello
on behalf of valve
shout out the valve hitting us up
the game hitting us up the game
my name is damien
in quotations damien marone
david [ __ ] salute he's he's not sure if
his name is damien [ __ ]
i'm the pr manager of valve
[Laughter]
we have contacted you to offer you
cooperation
what is that
[Music]
okay all right listen we need it we need
it yeah we need it exactly
we are interested in you as a person
you are active
positive
interesting and promising yes
we have assessed your channel
and it is your statistics that suits you
completely
is developing the game
skipper
skipping her skipping
and it is now the skipper the the the
follow-up to half-life alex the skipper
now
sensation skipper
now it is in beta testing
the release of the game is planned for
the near future okay and we would like
to invite you to repair it
[Music]
we're going to repair skipper this is
what we're going to do wow
so we're a company
there's more our company works only
under a contract
and after the conclusion of the contract
we make an advance payment of forty
percent so how how is it in famine
shout out to our late advanced bag we
gonna get for repairing an unreleased
game salute to skipper keep going this
is fire i like these opportunities
if you're interested in working with us
let me know
best regards valve company and pr
manager
damien marrone
listen you know what's crazy what if
whatever
no no
funny thing i read it i was like i need
to check this i need to bet this to be
sure because you never know you just
never know so i'm like the damon marone
does not exist dude what if jason's
trying next week be like codename
skipper half-life alex
and we blew the
opportunity to fix the game
to repair the game
yo that was born listen companies we
really appreciate this the fact that you
view us as developers that work
alongside to to provide that level of
input it's truly humbling it's truly
humbling in the front
office
that email
[Laughter]
so shout out to some shout out to them
shout out to valve oh
look great show again make sure you guys
subscribe to all these guys channels
acer flamish experience kids move the
best by playing at xbox game on daily
you know what i'm saying four guys with
four gq tv you know what i'm saying that
i see i got it i got it was it
retrograde against it you know what i'm
saying hey yeah salute to everybody
everybody enjoy your sunday got more fun
stuff planned next week there's gonna be
another one and you guys i'll catch you
next week we out
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
so